bien
c'est reprise je vous rappelle que pour
cette mission la Conférence des
Présidents a fixé la durée maximum de la
discussion à 2h30 en conséquence si nous
n'avions pas terminé l'examen de cette
mission à 18h10 elle se poursuivrait à
la fin des missions de cette semaine et
nous passerions à la directement à
l'examen de la mission média livre et
industrie culturel en revanche se
terminons avant le terme de la durée
l'examen de la mission suivante pourra
commencer sans attendre nous allons
procéder à l'examen des amendements
portant sur les crédits de la mission
culture figurant à l'état B et nous
commençons avec un amendement du
Gouvernement madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs l'amendement que
je vous présente à deux volets d'une
part sur le plan rédactionnel il vise à
annuler la création d'un cinquième
programme budgétaire au sein de la
mission culture qui était intitulée
éducation média et à l'information et
qui était très faiblement doté il est
proposé de repositionner les crédits
initialement ouverts pour la création de
ce programme budgétaire 500.000 euros
vers le programme 361 transmission des
savoirs et démocratisations de la
culture au sein duquel l'éducation aux
médias et à l'information constitue un
domaine prioritaire d'action et sur
lequel les ouvertures sur le programme
nouvellement créé avaient été
initialement gagé ça ça fait suite à
l'amendement de violettes spielbout à
l'Assemblée d'autre part il tire cet
amendement les conséquences de
l'adoption de plusieurs amendements
parlementaires
déposer et adopter à l'Assemblée
nationale en rehaussant de 3 millions
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement et
en crédit de paiement le programme
soutient aux politiques du ministère de
la Culture de la mission culture au
titre du développement du Pass Culture
en Nouvelle-Calédonie c'était
l'amendement de Nicolas metzorf d'une
aide pour les collectivités
territoriales afin d'assurer l'entretien
et la valorisation du patrimoine local
un amendement de Frédéric maillot un
million d'euros là aussi et enfin de
soutenir une politique de recrutement au
sein des fins phares un amendement
d'Alexandre portier à un million d'euros
qui vient compléter notre plan fanfare
que j'avais annoncé en reconduction à
hauteur de 1 million d'euros par an
voilà pour cet amendement du
Gouvernement quelle est la vie de la
commission le Président il s'agit d'un
amendement de coordination budgétaire
qui tire les conséquences budgétaires
des amendements retenus par le
gouvernement dans le texte adopté à
l'Assemblée donc à vif favorable je
mésoie cet amendement du Gouvernement
Calvi favorable de la commission qui est
pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il était
adopté le 507 monsieur brouiller merci
madame la ministre vous avez évoqué
l'enjeu décarbonation culture bienvenue
et les moyens consacrés aux équipements
nationaux notre amendement vise à
soutenir les politiques culturelles des
collectivités et des associations
qu'elle soutiennent face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie vous le savez les
collectivités dans les finances sont
déjà sous tension subissent également
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie
elle se trouve parfois contraintes
d'amputer des politiques culturelles de
diminuer les tranches les plages
horaires d'ouverture de certains
équipements pénalisant parfois des
coopérations avec les scolaires le
soutien des tiers-lieux ou à des
universités populaires dans les exemples
qui me sont revenus nous vous proposons
donc de créer un fond d'aide pour
accompagner les collectivités et leur
permettre de continuer à soutenir ce
maillage culturel local qu'elles
assurent quotidiennement les politiques
publiques culturelles sont essentielles
mais nous partageant cet avis à l'essor
d'une démocratie culturelle elles
doivent rester forte et assumer et
surtout ne pas devenir une variable
d'ajustement dans cette période de
graves crise budgétaire la commission
c'est une demande de retrait puisqu'il
nous semble que
cet objectif auquel il est possible de
souscrire bien entendu et parfaitement
pris en compte par les crédits du plan
de relance depuis 2021 par ailleurs le
dispositif est gagé sur l'intégralité
des crédits du Pass Culture ça nous
semble j'irai être un dommage collatéral
donc c'est une demande de retrait sinon
défavorablement
je rejoins merci Madame la présente la
vie du rapporteur effectivement nous
avons déjà pris en compte en large
partie un certain nombre de situations
très difficiles en matière de d'impact
du coût de l'énergie pour certains
opérateurs évidemment qu'en priorité
l'État est enceinte à financer certains
opérateurs nous devons nous préoccuper
de ceux que nous sommes seuls à financer
mais dans cette enveloppe nous
regarderons avec nos Dracs les cas les
plus critiques y compris pour les
structures co-financées avec les
collectivités donc nous serons au
rendez-vous autant que possible des cas
les plus critiques j'en profite aussi
pour vous signaler un appel à projet qui
s'appelle alternative verte dans le
cadre du Plan France 2030 qui est doté
de 10 millions d'euros déjà attribués et
que nous allons reconduire à hauteur de
10 millions d'euros pour financer là des
projets de décarbonation de la culture
qui permettront à plus long terme de
structurellement baisser ses factures
d'énergie je vous remercie avis demande
de retraite sinon défavorable ce bruit
merci merci de ces réponses pour leur
rapporteur spécial à l'évidence le gage
n'était pas fait pour diminuer les les
crédits mentionnés c'est la règle pour
échapper à l'article 40 je vais
maintenir cette amendement parce que je
garde une inquiétude madame la ministre
sur ce que seront le soutien en
collectivité territoriale après le 49-3
puisque malheureusement on n'est pas
garanti des résultats donc mais j'ai
bien entendu la réponse et l'hypothèse
que le fond que vous consacrez aux
équipements nationaux puissent
éventuellement être utilisés pour
d'autres équipements ayant convention
avec les dragues je préfère maintenir
l'amendement par précaution
si je mets aux voix cet amendement
double avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstiente n'est pas
adopté le 528 monsieur dessus merci
madame la Présidente c'est un Allemand
un amendement complémentaire au
précédent pour un dispositif plus
pérenne donc on le sait la rénovation
énergétique du bâti dans le fondamental
pour la transition avec la nécessité de
réduire les factures mais aussi et
surtout limiter les consommations pour
réduire l'impact environnemental mais
hormis le bâti il y a beaucoup à faire
par exemple sur les déplacements des
spectateurs des artistes ou des
prestataires sur les possibles mises en
commun des ressources pour éviter des
consommations superflues sur le degré de
sobriété à mettre en oeuvre en termes de
chauffage ou d'illumination et tout cela
les acteurs culturels en sont bien
conscients puisque lors du traditionnel
débat de clôture du Festival d'Avignon
cette année c'est toute une filière qui
a appelé à s'engager pour la transition
écologique du spectacle vivant
ils sont prêts à s'engager mais ils
demandent un soutien notamment financier
de leur ministère et c'est précisément
le but de cet abonnement et donc nous
proposons la mise en oeuvre d'un fonds
de 50 millions d'euros pour la
transition du spectacle de vivant afin
de permettre aux acteurs de réaliser
leurs ambitions louables et nécessaires
je vous remercie quelle est la vie de la
Commission
la Commission est mis un avis de demande
de retrait et nous semble que là encore
le plan de relance a mis en place un
fond pour les institutions de la
création en région sur la période 2021
2022 et donc il apparaît opportun à la
commission des finances d'attendre les
résultats de l'exécution en 2022 pour
évaluer les modalités éventuelles de
reconduction d'un tel dispositif et
évaluer les besoins les attentes qui
pourraient s'exprimer demande de retrait
oui
vous maintenez je mets au voie double
avis défavorable qui est pour
qui contre qui s'absint n'est pas adopté
le 656 monsieur filaire
oui un amendement
un grand succès auprès des jeunes depuis
son lancement 2019 plus de 10 millions
de réservations d'offres ont été déposés
par près de 11000 acteurs culturels les
achats soutiennent les diverses
composantes du secteur culturel
cependant les prestataires n'en tirent
pas tous les mêmes bénéfices on demande
en particulier aux acteurs digitaux de
proposer une offre gratuite pour être
référencé au Pass Culture sans
contrepartie dans ces conditions
aujourd'hui quand un jeune utilise son
passe s'il achète un livre le compte du
jeu n'est débité en fonction le
commerçant est payé les ayants droits
sont payés s'il achète un livre
numérique c'est la même chose mais si
l'achète un contenu d'audio numérique le
comte du jeu né débité en fonction mais
le prestataire n'est pas payé et le
prestataire paye les droits d'auteur
cette situation fragilise clairement
certains modèles économiques de
plateforme numérique française par
ailleurs cette politique dévalorise
l'audio numérique par rapport aux autres
biens culturels alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui le support économique
incontournable de l'industrie musicale
l'amendement propose par un fléchage à
hauteur de 10 millions d'euros d'inciter
le gouvernement à rétribuer les offres
culturelles numériques audio sur le
dispositif du bascule de la même façon
que les autres offres
quelle est la ville de la Commission
la présidente
de retrait je veux dire à Bernard
fieller que cet amendement ça renvoie à
la philosophe à la philosophie même du
poste culture le Pass Culture c'est un
outil qui doit permettre de faire
évoluer les pratiques culturelles et
énormes non garantir des rentes de
situations à des plateformes que
connaissent déjà les jeunes en découle
donc cette logique de nos remboursements
et puis notant par ailleurs que la la
musique enregistrée ne représente que 9%
des achats qui sont effectués sur
l'application donc nous ne sommes pas
utiles de revenir sur ce point voilà
donc je confirme
demande de retrait
merci madame la Présidente oui même avis
et je voulais vous préciser que les
acteurs numériques
monsieur fialer quand le Pass Culture a
été conçu ont été considérés comme des
partenaires de ce dispositif et ont
accepté ce principe de non remboursement
avant même de s'inscrire eux-mêmes sur
le Pass Culture ça fait partie de cette
petite part d'autofinancement du passe
culture par rapport au large budget de
l'État qui vient en appui donc et vous
le savez le plafond et les dépenses des
jeunes dans le numérique sur le Pass
Culture sur le plafonné à 100 euros et
comme ça vient d'être appelé c'est
effectivement de très faible montant à
ce stade une évolution ne paraît pas
indispensable mais nous resterons
évidemment vigilants à l'avenir
je vous retirez le 703 madame de la
pauvreté
oui madame la Présidente est amendement
visa souligner l'insuffisance du
financement de l'archéologie préventive
renforcée par l'inflation si les
subventions destinées aux 62
collectivités habilités à réaliser des
diagnostics archéologiques ont été
accrues cette augmentation demeure
insuffisante notamment contenu de
l'inflation pour financer à la hauteur
de leurs besoins les opérateurs publics
singulièrement les collectivités en
charge de cette mission et donc proposer
de rattraper ce besoin par un amendement
de crédit en abondant le programme 175
patrimoine à hauteur de 8 millions
d'euros afin que ces crédits bénéficient
ensuite à l'action neuve patrimoine
archéologique ce rateur se rattrapage me
semble d'autant plus justifiée que deux
amendements suivront afin d'augmenter
les moyens de ingrap par parallélisme se
décollectivités doivent donc l'être
aussi si les règles de recevabilité
budgétaire oblige à gâcher cette
proposition par un transfert de crédit
provenant d'autres programmes de la
mission en l'occurrence le Pass Culture
je souhaite néanmoins la levée du gage
et la pérennité des autres dispositions
de cette mission je vous remercie merci
vis-à-vis de la Commission
le projet de loi de finance prévoit
environ 9 millions d'euros au titre des
dépenses de soutien fouillis
archéologiques programmé réalisé par les
collectivités territoriales en
partenariat avec d'autres organismes ce
montant progresse de 4 millions d'euros
par rapport à 2022 il a pour ambition
une sincérisation des crédits cette
sincérisation elle va dans le bon sens
elle constitue une première étape et il
a semblé à la commission des finances
que les résultats de l'exécution 2023
nous donneront des éléments en vue
d'adapter ultérieurement le dispositif
mais en l'état c'est une demande de
retrait sinon défavorable
madame la Présidente merci madame la
sénatrice de la pauvreté c'est vraiment
un des sujets qui a fait partie des des
plus forts moments de ma négociation
budgétaire de cet été et des priorités
que j'ai voulu porter j'en avais aussi
parlé plusieurs fois avec François
sauvadel président de la situation des
départements de France je sais que de
nombreux élus sont soucieux de cet enjeu
de l'archéologie préventive au terme de
toutes ces discussions j'ai obtenu tout
de même une hausse de 20% des crédits
par rapport à l'an dernier je trouve que
c'est un une évolution assez
significative nous pourrons en faire le
bilan à l'issue des prochains mois pour
voir comment faire évoluer aussi ces
arguments budgétaires pour l'avenir
merci à vous demande de retrait
également monsieur Canevet
merci madame la Présidente je voulais
juste appeler la tension du gouvernement
sur la situation d'un certain nombre
soit de connectivité soit d'entreprises
soit de particulier qui ont des terrains
sur lesquels il y a des vestiges qui
sont découverts et la charge de la
fouille une fois que peut être identifié
le potentiel potentiel présent de
vestiges et particulièrement lourdes et
conviendrait que des dispositifs
d'accompagnement puissent être mis en
oeuvre parce que aujourd'hui alors que
le coup de logement par exemple est très
élevé et bien tout cela aboutit un
russement du coût des opérations et ceci
est particulièrement préjudiciable à
l'accès au logement de tous c'est donc
je souhaite que le gouvernement puisse
étudier l'accompagnement de ces acteurs
je vais donc Madame doit provoquer
oui madame oui c'était bien entendu
vous remarque et le cette hausse de 20%
du budget
donc je propose de retirer l'amendement
avec un rendez-vous certains pour le
projet prochain projet de loi de finance
puisque comme le dit comme cela a été
dit justement c'est une première étape
et je rappelle que les collectivités
territoriales ont une place vraiment
particulière dans le dispositif
d'archéologie préventive avec un
engagement auprès de la protection du
parc patrimoine archéologique certains
et donc à ce titre là elles doivent être
considérées comme étant partie plein et
entière de cette politique je vous
remercie merci nous passons 396 Monsieur
Madame meunier merci Madame à la
présidente mes chers collègues donc sur
les exercices précédents les crédits du
plan de relance sont constitués une
garantie non négligeable pour que les
acteurs du patrimoine mais ils ont aussi
engendré une augmentation d'activités en
manière en matière d'aménagement et de
construction
qui devrait se poursuivre en 23 cette
situation des conséquences directes en
matière d'archéologie préventive avec un
surcroît d'activité dont on se réjouit
mais que l'INRA et les services agréés
des collectivités territoriales doivent
pouvoir assumer en matière de diagnostic
il apparaît notamment que les aménageurs
publics ou privés sont aujourd'hui
satisfaits des délais d'exécution des
opérations de diagnostic ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas aussi dans le souci
de préserver des relations apaisées avec
des aménageurs cet amendement propose
d'octroyer 5 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à l'INRA afin de
permettre à l'Institut d'assumer les
demandes opérations actuelles et prévues
pour 2023 liés à la recrudence
recrudescence des prescriptions à la
suite de la crise sanitaire donc on
propose d'abonder 5 millions dans
l'action neuf programme 175 patrimoine
et de minorer du même montant l'action 7
fonctions et soutien ministère du
programme de 124
pour l'identique merci madame la
présidente Madame la mise mais mes chers
collègues j'ai eu à pratiquer c'est un
souvenir d'anciens combattants la loi de
1941 sur l'archéologie et je me souviens
avec quelle difficulté
y compris dans cette musique la nouvelle
loi sur l'arc présentive a été votée et
je suis très heureux de voir que
aujourd'hui les élus la défendent et
souhaitent même que l'INRAP participe
davantage à cette mission de service
public j'ai entendu aussi madame lamise
vos engagements forts pour l'archéologie
préventive et je et je m'en réjouis
parce que je crois que le développement
économique ne peut pas les à l'encontre
du patrimoine et je reprends les mots
très juste de mon collègue mes Brisson à
propos des des énergies renouvelables là
en l'occurrence ce qu'on aimerait c'est
que les aides de l'INRA pour réaliser le
diagnostic soit beaucoup plus dynamique
qu'elle puisse s'adapter presque en de
façon continue
à l'énorme cahier des charges auxquelles
l'INRAP et les services des
collectivités parce qu'ils sont
complémentaires et très souvent dans les
départements ils ont passé des
conventions pour travailler ensemble
donc j'ai compris aujourd'hui que Bercy
vous demandez un bilan ce qui
s'intéressant c'est que dans une future
loi de de finance rectificative on
puisse ajuster cette subvention à l'INRA
pour lui permettre de réaliser les
diagnostics et afin de ne pas ralentir
les travaux je pense que c'est tout à
fait essentiel pour continuer à faire
que l'archéologie préventive au jour
aujourd'hui soit politiquement
acceptable merci Madame président quelle
est la vie de la Commission sur ces deux
amendements identiques
ainsi que sur l'amendement précédent de
notre collègue de la pauvreté nous avons
une évolution des crédits prévus dans le
projet de loi de finance sur ces
questions
mais là il s'agit de financer l'INRAP or
il est indiqué que les 4,8 millions
d'euros supplémentaires sur l'exercice
de 1023
couvre pour 2 millions 6 l'inflation et
pour 2 millions 2 la progression des
salaires des agents donc ces nouveaux
crédits ne couvrent pas l'augmentation
du nombre de diagnostics réalisés et
donc la charge pour l'opérateur qui
était déjà en évolution importante
puisqu'on en avait 1842 en 2020 et 2019
en 2021 nous souhaiterions donc savoir
comment le ministère envisage avec
l'opérateur cette augmentation du nombre
de ces interventions de nouvelles règles
sont-elles envisagées pour alléger cette
charge nous avons dans notre rapport de
contrôle sur le financement de la
recherche patrimoniale avec Didier
Rambaud publies en février dernier
insisté sur la nécessité de renforcer
par exemple les liens entre le drame au
sujet des diagnostics archéologiques
subaquatiques nous appelions notamment à
la systématisation de conventions
d'évaluation archéologique tarifs entre
les opérateurs numériques et le drasme
pour éviter le risque d'intervention à
perte pour l'INRAP qu'en est-il et donc
notre avis et la vie de la commission
des finances sur ce sujet est un appel à
la vie du gouvernement
madame la ministre
si madame la Présidente vous êtes je
suis ravie de voir autant de
spécialistes de l'archéologie au Sénat
c'est réjouissant
j'étais samedi à Villers-Cotterêts et
j'ai échangé d'ailleurs avec les agents
de l'INRA qui m'ont montré les résultats
de leur fouille et c'est impressionnant
nous aurons là de magnifiques
découvertes qui vont enrichir notre
découverte de l'histoire
là effectivement nous avons un
relèvement de 5% qui permet de
d'absorber le contexte de hausse des
prix à hauteur de 2,6 millions et
d'accompagner la réforme de la
revalorisation salariale des agents à
hauteur de 2,2 millions comme vous venez
de le dire mais cette mesure vient en
complément des hausses intervenues en
2021 et 2022 5 millions 2021 1,5
millions en 2022 et surtout des crédits
importants du plan de relance qui était
de 34,5 millions déjà avant le plan de
relance en 2020 et 20 millions dans le
plan de relance moi je serai vigilante
en gestion parce que là je j'ai pas pu
obtenir plus que tout ce que j'avais
déjà obtenu sur l'archéologie et qui me
semblait suffisamment satisfaisant mais
en gestion ministère on a bien nous la
visibilité des chantiers de ce qui
progresse donc on je serai vraiment très
attentive à rééquilibrer chaque fois que
possible donc c'est une demande de
retrait pour le gouvernement la vie de
la commission après avoir entendu la
ministre
on va rester sur un avis de sagesse
madame la Présidente chacun appréciera
en fonction des éléments de réponse on a
compris que madame la ministre avait
négocié son budget elle a pas obtenu
satisfaction en tout point peut-être
pouvons-nous l'aider
très bien je vais mettre on voit cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis sagesse de
la Commission à naviguer favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
le madame paoligajin pour le 691 oui
merci madame la Présidente il s'agit
d'un amendement qui vise à augmenter les
crédits prévus par la mission pour la
reconversion de du site de l'abbaye de
Clairvaux je vous rappelle mes chers
collègues c'est une abbaye qui a été
fondée en 1115 par Bernard de Clairvaux
c'est un site patrimonial culturel et
historique hors du commun en effet cette
abbaye cistercienne s'est développée
pendant près du siècle jusqu'à devenir
bien national en 1792 après la
Révolution à l'initiative de Napoléon
elle est reconvertie au début du XIXe en
prison devenant de ce fait un haut lieu
de l'histoire carcérale de notre pays
elle a notamment accueilli Claude Gueux
dont Victor Hugo s'est inspiré pour l'un
de ses romans
désormais l'état engager la fermeture de
la prison et lancer un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt comme je le
disais tout à l'heure les premiers
résultats ont été annoncés le 12
novembre dernier plusieurs dossiers de
candidatures sont en lice partageant
tous l'ambition de faire de Clairvaux un
lieu de culture au rayonnement
international comme il le fut autant des
cisterciens et de redynamisation pour le
tissu économique local on exploitant au
mieux toute la richesse patrimoniale du
site cette reconversion implique ainsi
une mobilisation massive de capitaux
privés afin d'engager d'importants
travaux de restauration et le lancement
de nouvelles activités en lien avec le
projet qui sera finalement retenu
ce flux financier s'articulera avec les
crédits inscrits par la Mission culture
à hauteur de 15 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et 2 millions
en crédit de paiement prévu par l'action
0 monument historiques et patrimoine
monumental du programme patrimoine le
rapport des rapporteurs spéciaux pour la
commission des finances indique que le
montant des autorisations d'engagement
prévues ne représentent au mieux que 10%
du coût total du chantier qui est estimé
je vous le rappelle entre 150 et 200
millions d'euros
afin d'augmenter les moyens consacrés
par l'État dès 2023 à la reconversion du
site notre amendement prévoit de retenir
le même pourcentage de 10% en
l'appliquant à la borne supérieure de la
fourchette estimée des travaux en outre
afin d'assurer un décaissement rapide de
ces crédits et de ne pas provoquer de
retard dans le lancement du projet de
reconversion il est prévu de mettre en
correspondance le montant des crédits de
paiement avec celui des autorisations
d'engagement natrices ouais désolé c'est
bon oui
l'objet était effectivement fourni
quelle est la ville de la Commission
oui nous avions indiqué je l'ai répété
dans mon intervention tout à l'heure que
nous sommes réservés sur la dotation de
15 millions en autorisation d'engagement
pour un projet d'une ampleur
considérable parce que ce monument pour
ceux qui le connaissent et est un
monument extrêmement important en volume
et en qualité patrimoniale néanmoins
les premiers résultats de l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêts ont été rendus
publics à deux semaines il va y avoir de
nombreux mois d'ajustement évidemment du
projet de négociation de façon à pouvoir
définir un montant d'autorisation
d'engagement définitif donc en l'état de
l'avancement du dossier 15 millions ne
nous paraissent ne nous paraissent pas
impossible à entendre et donc c'est un
avis de demande de retrait
madame la ministre
si madame la Présidente je suis d'accord
en tout point à ce que vient de dire
monsieur le rapporteur
c'est vraiment un des chantiers qui nous
tient le plus à coeur d'ailleurs je
l'avais mis en avant dans mes exemples
lors de ma conférence de presse
budgétaire
tout de même c'est encourageant on a 9
candidats qui se sont présentés 9
groupements privés attendons de voir
trois d'entre eux ont été sélectionnés
dans la première sortie
le l'ampleur des travaux les projets
entrons dans le détail c'est le budget
2023 on aura aussi les budgets 2024 et
au-delà pour accompagner ce chantier
bien sûr donc demande de retrait
je vais mettre voix cet amendement qui a
pardon
un monsieur zoulias
merci madame le Président pardon je vous
prends de quelques secondes même la
ministre moi je voudrais marquer mon
attachement très fort à ce à ce lieu de
mémoire d'abord parce que c'est un
édifice culturel extrêmement important
et y compris pour le rayonnement de
l'artiste tertia et puis c'est le lieu
où des résistants nombreux ont été
incarcérées et ont été fusillés et je
pense que aujourd'hui alors que nous
vivons partout une montée des périls
c'est très important de rappeler cette
mémoire et vous permettrez
un commentaire très personnel c'est là
où mon arrière-grand-père Maurice
romagon a été fusillé le 7 mars 1942
merci Madame président
merci je vais donc mettre voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
qu'est-ce que
donc le pour j'enlève tout à l'heure
on va recommencer mais vous devez lever
la main qu'une seule fois je vous
rappelle
qui est pour
qu'est-ce que vous faites là
bon bah du coup maintenant c'est bon ça
passe pas
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté
le 495 madame Monnier plusieurs rapports
récents du Sénat soulignent que les
Dracs n'ont pas suffisamment de moyens
humains pour pouvoir accompagner les
collectivités territoriales notamment en
matière d'ingénierie un rapport
thématique rendu en juin dernier par la
Cour des comptes évoque quant à lui la
situation
préoccupante des architectes des
bâtiments de France face aux difficultés
pour les collectivités territoriales à
assurer l'entretien et la valorisation
du patrimoine local les effectifs des
udapes s'avère insuffisant et ne sont
plus en mesure de répondre aux demandes
des collectivités le nombre
d'architectes des bâtiments de France
semble décliner progressivement comme
d'ailleurs l'attractivité de cette
carrière les places au concours
n'arrivent plus à être y intégralement
pourvu ce manque d'attractivité réside
sans doute dans une rémunération un peu
faible des ABS dépendant du ministère de
la Culture mais certainement davantage
dans les conditions d'exercices
difficiles compte tenu de leur petit
nombre et d'une ombre très élevée manuel
a donné ses moyens humains insuffisants
provoquent un allongement des délais
d'inscription des dossiers et on
ralentissement des chantiers mettant
ainsi un péril la protection des sites
dans les ABS sont les garant au regard
des besoins d'expertise patrimoniales
croissant dans les territoires le
recrutement d'un architecte bâtiment de
France supplémentaire par département
qui doit constituer un objectif à moyen
terme permettrait de renforcer le
contrôle scientifique et technique de
l'État sur ces projets de restauration
et de conservation patrimoniale et
d'offrir une assistance à maîtrise
d'ouvrages minimale aux porteur de
projets donc cet amendement c'est 3
millions d'euros supplémentaires à
l'action monument historique j'ai
conscience qu'il faudra aussi envisager
de travailler à une meilleure
attractivité du métier et comme je viens
de le dire ça serait déjà elle serait
déjà sensiblement améliorée si la charge
de travail des ABS était moins lourde
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
alors je rappelle que la majoration des
crédits dédiés au drive en faveur des
patrimoine rejoint une préoccupation
ancienne de la commission des finances
nous avions ciblé d'ailleurs en 2018 à
l'occasion d'une mission de contrôle le
manque de moyens pour les déplacements
des agents ou encore la faible
attractivité financière des métiers une
partie de ce sujet a été résolue par le
plan de rattrapage indemnitaire pour
autant celui-ci ne résout pas toutes les
difficultés notons cependant que le
gouvernement entendu cet intérêt en
acceptant une une majoration des crédits
affectés au DRAC à hauteur de 1 million
d'euros en reprenant un amendement qui
avait été déposé à l'Assemblée nationale
dans le texte transmis dans ces
conditions il est peut-être envisagé
d'attendre les premiers résultats de
l'exécution 2023 pour envisager une
nouvelle majoration de crédit aussi
c'est une demande de retrait
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente en effet
juste en complément
précisé que l'effectif que ce soit pour
les architectes des bâtiments de France
ou les ingénieurs ou les techniciens n'a
pas diminué ces dernières années au
contraire le ministère de la culture
c'est attaché à reconstituer cet
effectif dans les départements où il y
avait eu des baisses et en réalité
aujourd'hui notre enjeu est pas
tellement un enjeu de nombre de TP mais
c'est plutôt qu'on fait face à des
vacances de poste à un baisse du nombre
de candidats quand on lance des concours
et donc on a un enjeu de travailler sur
l'attractivité du métier des architectes
des bâtiments de France
ce dont on a discuter lors d'un
séminaire où je les ai tous réunis il y
a quelques jours travailler avec l'Ordre
des architectes bref on a avancé
plusieurs pistes pour améliorer
l'attractivité de ce métier donc pour
moi c'est une demande de retrait parce
que l'amendement ne répond pas
pleinement à la difficulté qui est celle
de l'attractivité aujourd'hui
mais je profite d'être au micro pour
remercier tous les sénateurs sur ces
bancs et ceux qui ne sont pas là mais
qui s'étaient mobilisés récemment dans
les débats pour défendre le rôle des ABS
je sais que vous connaissez très bien la
l'importance de leur mission et pour
défendre leur avis conforme pour
continuer à concilier le développement
des énergies renouvelables et la
préservation du patrimoine merci à vous
tous pour cet engagement
madame Monnier il est maintenu donc je
mets aux voix double avis madame Robert
oui je voudrais vraiment souligner cette
amendement même si il ne répond pas
complètement à la situation je voudrais
vous dire et on le sait que la question
de l'ingénierie dans les Dracs est un
vrai sujet pour les collectivités
territoriales la question des ABS on l'a
vu dans le projet de loi sur les
énergies renouvelables et venus c'est
vraiment ce serait un signal très
important que de voter cet amendement
parce que je pense que c'est un sujet
qui reviendra et qu'il faut vraiment
conforter les dragues sur le sujet merci
beaucoup monsieur Brisson pour ne pas
rajouter je voudrais simplement dire que
je soutiens que j'appuie sur une dédiée
Robert merci donc je vais mettre voix
cet amendement qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'obstient il est adopté le 356
madame Robert
pardon je me mets là pour pas vous
tourner le dos donc c'est un moment que
je porte au niveau de la commission
culture il vise à permettre aux écoles
territoriales d'appliquer aux étudiants
boursiers le même niveau d'exonération
que dans les écoles nationales on
compensant pour elle les effets de cette
mesure à hauteur de 2,5 millions d'euros
alors que les écoles nationales et les
écoles territoriales délivrent les mêmes
diplômes leur étudiants n'ont pas les
mêmes droits aujourd'hui la
revalorisation des bourses sur critères
sociaux destinés aux étudiants des
écoles nationales en 2023 risque encore
de creuser l'écart entre les écoles
nationales et les écoles territoriales
et d'accroître ainsi les inégalités de
traitement entre les étudiants la
diversité sociale et culturelle étant
une politique portée par l'État et non
par les collectivités territoriales il
m'apparaît logique de prévoir ce
transfert de crédit
que David la commission parce que je
vois la présidente en effet cette
ouverture de crédit s'inscrit dans la
dans le prolongement de la majoration
des bourses sur critères sociaux versés
aux étudiants des écoles nationales
prévues dans le présent PLF je rappelle
plus 7,5 millions d'euros il convient
simplement de rappeler à ce stade que
les aides individuelles pour le soutien
en pratique artistique des élèves de
l'enseignement initial dans les domaines
du spectacle vivant sont déjà versés aux
élèves des conservatoires à rayonnement
départemental et régional dès lors
qu'ils sont adossés à des pôles
d'enseignement supérieur du spectacle
vivant une dotation de 1,6 millions
d'euros et prévu dans le présent PLF la
majoration des crédits dédiés de 2,5
millions d'euros prévu dans le présent
amendement viendrait donc plus que
doubler cette enveloppe nous avions avec
Vincent et blé dans notre rapport de
contrôle sur l'enseignement supérieur du
spectacle vivant rendu public en février
dernier appelé à une clarification des
modalités de financement des écoles
territoriales
la règle à la matière peut en première
analyse apparaître obscur et jugé et
sont jugés inégal selon les les dragues
l'octroi de nouveaux crédit devrait donc
être précédé d'une mise à plat du
financement de l'État dans le
prolongement d'ailleurs de la réforme
des conservatoires qui semblent peiner à
se déployer néanmoins contenus du
contexte inflationniste comme du risque
de décalage entre les établissements
nationaux et les écoles territoriales
une majoration immédiate peut être jugée
opportunes aussi c'est un avis favorable
merci quelle est la vie du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente
alors c'est un sujet très important
puisque comme je l'ai dit rapidement
dans mon propos liminaire j'ai vraiment
mis au cœur de mes priorités
l'amélioration des de la situation des
établissements d'enseignements
supérieurs artistique avec une priorité
pour les écoles d'architecture en
particulier et globalement on n'a pas du
tout oublié les écoles d'artéritoriales
avec 10 millions d'euros en
investissements 21 millions en
fonctionnement
c'est ça en fait qui nous a été remonté
des besoins d'investissement de mise aux
normes des besoins de rebazage en
fonctionnement avec aussi l'inflation
que vous connaissez je vous assure que
de tous les échanges chez peu à voir
avec l'Association des Régions l'AMF la
situation des départements même la FNCC
ça ne faisait pas partie des priorités
qui qui m'ont été
soulevés ni cet été ni cet automne à ce
stade nous et rappelons quand même que
les taux d'inscription sont très bas
dans ces écoles on est en France parmi
les plus bas d'Europe par rapport à
d'autres pays donc pour moi la priorité
n'était pas là j'avoue la autorité était
sur l'accompagnement d'investissement
l'accompagnement en fonctionnement et on
a mis les budgets donc pour moi c'est un
avis défavorable bien
je vais donc mettre en voix cet
amendement qui a reçu un avis favorable
de la commission et défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre il est adopté madame Robert
le 357
oui donc je vais parler des écoles
d'architecture puisque là aussi au nom
de la commission de la culture c'est
amendement donc vise à revaloriser de
2,2 millions d'euros le montant des
crédits destiné à compenser la hausse
des salaires des enseignants
contractuels des Ensor en effet le coût
de cette mesure a été évalué à 4
millions d'euros en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on nous a dit dans l'audition et le
projet de loi de finance ne comporte
qu'un virgule 8 millions d'euros à ce
titre cette mesure apparaît donc
indispensable pour permettre aux ensa
qui c'est vrai dont le budget a augmenté
vous l'avez dit et j'ai d'ailleurs je
l'ai dit dans ma DG de retrouver des
marges de manœuvre financière leur
permettant de maintenir un enseignement
de qualité car derrière il y a aussi
d'autres questions qui viennent impacter
leur budget je vous remercie quelle est
la ville de la commission des finances
et sur ce sujet ne semble pas qu'il y
ait de désaccord de fond tout le monde
convient qu'une revalorisation de la
rémunération des enseignants chercheurs
dans les écoles d'architecture et
nécessaires
mais le processus est engagé dans le
présent projet de loi de finance à
hauteur d'un million
650 millions d'euros 650
000 euros et donc la Commission a
considérer que c'était une première
étape et que il convenait de demander le
retrait
quelle est la vie du gouvernement
je mets aux voix qui est pour
il est adopté
j'attire votre attention sur le fait
qu'il ne reste 15 directement 15 minutes
et 6 amendements examiné chacun prend
les deux minutes ça passe pas donc tout
le monde a compris le message j'imagine
monsieur Breuillet pour les agences
des dispositions ont été prises par
l'État des collectivités territoriales
et des établissements culturels pour
mettre en place dans une certaine mesure
la gratuité des musées pour les 18-25
ans la plupart du temps elles sont
soumises à des modalités d'application
variable de jours d'horaires et d'offres
artistiques notre amendement vise à
généraliser cette gratuité nous sommes
conscients qu'elle n'est pas la réponse
unique à l'enjeu de démocratisation de
la culture elle permet cependant de
lever le premier frein je me permets de
souligner que le Val-de-Marne avait mené
une étude sur la non fréquentation sur
les gens qui ne fréquentaient pas le
magval et que les deux réponses qui
venaient la première était ce n'est pas
pour moi et la deuxième était le coût
est trop élevé malgré un tarif très peu
dissuasif donc nous vous demandons
d'investir en direction de la jeunesse
évidemment nous souhaitons que le gage
soit levé quelle est la vie de la
Commission
alors effectivement on considère que ça
va être un amendement d'appel qui est
incontestablement séduisant je me
permets de vous rappeler que le Pass
Culture tente d'y répondre partiellement
en intégrant les musées dans son offre
dédiés en partie au 18-20 ans il sent
quand même néanmoins difficiles pour
l'État d'imposer
à la totalité des musées notamment
privés cette gratuité fut-elle compensée
donc c'est un avis de retrait
quelle est la vie du gouvernement
même avis d'autant plus que le mag va
l'exemple que vous avez cité est sur le
Pass Culture et en bénéficient tous les
musées nationaux sont déjà gratuits pour
les moins de 25 voire 26 ans on ne peut
pas imposer au musée territoriaux leur
politique tarifaire libre administration
des collectivités territoriales en
revanche par le Pass Culture collectif
les sorties au musée se développent par
le Pass Culture individuel également et
par nos aides via les draps un ensemble
de programmes comme l'été culturel qui
permettent aussi l'été de permettre à
des
populations notamment jeunes qui ne
peuvent pas partir en vacances d'aller
aussi au musée demande de retrait
je vais donc mettre au voie vous
maintenez je mets au bois cet amendement
double avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abset n'est pas adopté de 524
monsieur dessus merci madame la
Présidente donc les associations de
réduction des risques sont présentes
dans de nombreux festivals ou cancers au
concert pardon pour cent de civiliser le
public au risque lié aux usages de
drogue leur action permet de réduire le
nombre d'overdose d'identifier de
sensibiliser les usagers sur les
produits les plus dangereux or cette
présence essentielle est loin d'être
garantie pour tous les événements à
travers cet amendement nous souhaitons
pousser vers la généralisation de la
présence de ces associations en milieu
festif bien souvent ce sont les
collectivités seuls qui accordent leur
subventions à ces associations il est
temps que l'État s'engage davantage
de la Commission
bien sûr on peut pas être contre
l'objectif mais ce n'est pas le lieu
nous pensons qu'un dispositif créé au
sein de la mission culture contribuerait
un esclage regrettable des moyens
budgétaires des dialy à la lutte contre
ces addictions et donc c'est une demande
de retrait aussi non des favorable
en parler avec mon collègue François
Brown parce que ça relève davantage de
la santé je connais bien l'association
technopôle qui notamment agit de manière
très forte sur ces sujets j'en profite
que je n'avais pas eu le temps d'en
parler tout à l'heure pardon madame la
présente je prends une minute pour vous
remercier de votre attention sur le
sujet des festivals au moment des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 nous sommes en plein
dans un travail très méthodique région
par région phase par phase cas par cas
pour permettre à ces festivals de se
décaler de quelques jours de revoir leur
formation besoin et de pouvoir se tenir
en fait seuls sont concernés les
festivals mobilisants des unités de
force mobile des recours nationaux en
unité de force mobile donc déjà on ne
parle pas de tous les festivals de
France je vais vous rassurer là dessus
ce pointage a été fait de manière très
précise et nous sommes en plein dialogue
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur la
ministre des Sports et les préfets
concernés et ce dialogue est très
constructif à ce stade je voulais vous
rassurer là-dessus
merci je mets the western à ma demande
mon double vie défavorable qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstein n'est pas
adopté monsieur fialer le 657 oui je
vais vous résumer cet amendement de
notre collègue Guylaine Pantel qui vise
à soutenir les collectivités
territoriales pour l'entretien et la
valorisation du patrimoine local on sait
combien ce patrimoine du pigeonnier au
lavoir en passant par la demeure de
maître et le musée ou le musée de
proximité signe l'identité de nos villes
et visages villages donc je vous épargne
tous les arguments pour vous dire que
sans méconnaître les moyens VIP qui
accompagnent les communes à faible
ressources nous souhaitons par cet
amendement soutenir davantage des
collectivités territoriales pour
l'entretien et la valorisation du
patrimoine local qui a fait toute la
richesse de la France
c'est une demande de retrait en raison
de l'existence dans le projet de loi de
finance de crédit d'un fond incitatif et
partenarial qui est déjà majoré donc la
commission des finances a estimée que
cette demande était déjà satisfaite du
gouvernement mais ma vie je mets aux
retirez le madame meunier le 496
monsieur stanzen
[Musique]
propose en complément du FIP visant à
aider les collectivités à faible
ressources à financer les travaux
d'entretien de restauration et de mise
en valeur des monuments historiques de
créer un fond d'expérimentation
permettant aux drag que de proposer une
assistance à maîtrise d'ouvrage à titre
gracieux en direction de ces mêmes
collectivités le récent rapport de la
Cour des comptes sur la politique de
l'État en faveur du patrimoine
monumental établi en effet que cette
disposition prévue dans le code du
patrimoine depuis que la maîtrise
d'ouvrage des travaux sur les monuments
a été rendus aux propriétaires a été
très peu suivi des faits en effet il
existe dans de nombreuses collectivités
un besoin d'accompagnement technique des
porteurs de projets publics dans la non
satisfaction contribue à entretenir la
sous-consommation des crédits consacrés
aux monuments historiques ce point est
corroboré par le dispositif mis en place
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années par
la drague de Bretagne
quelle est la ville la commission
c'est une demande de retrait parce
qu'une majoration de la dotation des
dragues de 1 million d'euros présenté
par un rendement à l'Assemblée nationale
a été retenu par le gouvernement dans le
texte transmis donc demande de retraite
mais ma vie je mets aux voix qui est
pour qui compte qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté
nous allons procéder au vote des crédits
de la mission culture figurant à l'étape
des crédits de la mission je vous
rappelle que la vie de la commission des
finances est favorable à l'adoption de
ces crédits pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés j'appelle en discussion des
articles 41 quathériques inquièces
rattaché à la mission culture avec un
amendement 8 de Monsieur et blé
monsieur Rambaud
merci de la présidente donc la
généralisation du Pass Culture pose
plusieurs questions visant à la fois les
publics concernés mais aussi la qualité
de l'offre le présent article
additionnel cible spécifiquement le
sujet de son déploiement en milieu rural
qui pose avant tout la question de
l'offre culturelle dans ces territoires
si pertinent que soit cet angle les
pistes d'amélioration du dispositif
doivent également concerner l'accès des
jeunes ayant quitté les structures
scolaires quel que soit la zone
géographique où ils évoluent les projets
rapports annuels de performance document
déjà précisément l'évolution du
dispositif le rapport annuel d'activité
de la SAS de la SAS espace culture
détail également les modalités de
recours à l'application en ciblant
notamment les actions en direction des
publics les plus éloignés dans ces
conditions il est proposé de supprimer
cet article avis du gouvernement
sagesse sagesse je mets au voile
amendement de 8 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il était
adopté et l'article est donc supprimer
le 9
se remettre en question la pertinence du
sujet de l'accès aux infrastructures
culturelles il est possible s'interroger
sur la nécessité d'inscrire en loi de
finance la remise d'un rapport la
commission des finances est
traditionnellement assez réservée aux
nombreux rapports qui sont sollicités à
l'occasion d'examen de la loi de finance
en l'occurrence celui-ci ne concerne
qu'une partie des territoires très
marins ne visent une fine et que
l'action de la seule direction des
affaires culturelles de Guadeloupe
puisque les îles Saint-Martin et
Saint-Barthélémy relève du ressort de
celle-ci dans ces conditions il est
proposé de supprimer cet article à la
ministre
sagesse je mets aux voix cet amendement
de sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
et donc l'article est supprimé nous
passons maintenant au crédit de la
mission média livre et industrie
culturelle du compte spécial avance à
l'audiovisé le public et du projet web
finance considéré comme adopté à
l'Assemblée et la parole est au rapport
spécial de la commission des finances
monsieur carrosschi
madame la ministre madame la Présidente
je ne sais pas si c'est utile de faire
le tour complet des éléments de crédit
de cette mission je vais plutôt tout à
l'heure répondre aux amants je voudrais
juste vous dire que nous avons à la fois
un premier secteur livre industrie
culturelle
qui est un secteur qui a des problèmes à
des difficultés
liées d'ailleurs essentiellement à la
non reprise de la fréquentation des
salles malgré une atténuation du covid
que ce soit les cinémas que ce soit les
festivals que ce soit les théâtres que
ce soit les bibliothèques la
fréquentation n'est plus n'est pas
redevenu celle d'avant 2020 donc là nous
avons un problème je le dis tout de
suite puisqu'il va y avoir une série
d'amendements nous avons reçu notamment
les responsables du CNC les responsables
du CNM les responsables de la
Bibliothèque nationale de France
chacun a naturellement des difficultés
mais
sur le CNC
globalement avec des méthodes diverses
globalement le financement reste
conséquent se pose la question de savoir
si le CNC a raison de financer un
certain nombre de films ou de séries que
l'on a retrouvé sur Netflix ça c'est un
autre sujet mais bon le CNC dispose
quand même de moyens conséquents même si
la baisse de fréquentation des salles
reste conséquente de l'ordre de 20% par
rapport à ce qu'elle était en 2019
le problème du du CNM est plus compliqué
le CNM n'a pas pour le moment trouvé
réellement sa place ou plus exactement
il a pas trouvé madame la ministre les
financements nécessaires alors pour
l'année prochaine je
on a à peu près
trouver ou en tout cas par redéploiement
les financements mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut réfléchir tout de suite à d'autres
sources de financement à une autre
organisation pour que le CNM ne se
retrouve pas dans une très grave
difficulté en 2024
là-dessus il y a un certain nombre de
propositions qui ont été faites nous
attendons de votre part de nous dire
quels sont les pistes qui peuvent
effectivement
renforcer stabiliser le monde de la
musique
la BNF à la BNF c'est un problème
permanent madame la ministre pour le
moment alors j'ai bien vu un amendement
tout à l'heure mais je donnerai un avis
négatif mais Messi mais négatif parce
que j'allais presque dire il faut ou
beaucoup plus ou reposer le problème la
BNF a des problèmes d'investissement
d'abord parce que le bâtiment c'est
comme ça comment ça vieillir et
[Musique]
vous avez dix mille fenêtres à refaire
16000 euros la fenêtre 160 millions
si vous avez ça en magasin on les attend
mais jusqu'ici j'ai pas vu donc c'est
clair que on a un problème c'est le
paquebot de la lecture en France mais un
paquebot tellement lourd que je ne sais
pas jusqu'où il va falloir aller au
niveau des investissements pour
maintenir la qualité de service
l'étendue de la BNF et puis soyons
francs au début lorsqu'on a construit la
BNF tout le monde pensait qu'on allait
tellement vers le numérique qu'on allait
plus devoirs tellement stocker du papier
et c'est comme ça il continuait à y
avoir un dépôt de documents de livres
extrêmement important le résultat des
courses
c'est que bah on a créé un nouveau
centre de documentation à l'extérieur et
puis on se dit déjà qu'à l'heure qu'il
est même pas construit et même pas livré
il sera probablement insuffisant d'ici
450 et qu'il faudra peut-être envisager
encore un autre et on se dit bon bah
voilà il faut clairement recalibrer le
budget lecture dans ce pays d'autant que
soyons francs la BNF absorbe tellement
de crédit que pardon pour tous les élus
de province il reste pas grand chose
pour les bibliothèques de province parce
que la BNF est quand même un gouffre bon
alors un gouffre
utile mais c'est un gouffre donc les
bibliothèques de province ont du mal
elle à survivre devant un tel paquebot
enfin Madame la Ministre dans les deux
minutes et qui me reste l'audiovisuel
public
alors là pour ne rien vous cacher je
vous l'avais dit d'ailleurs
on s'est retrouvé devant la promesse du
candidat président ou du président
candidat de supprimer la contribution de
l'audiovisuel public la présentant sous
forme de de finalement de gains pour les
citoyens en pouvoir d'achat sauf que
[Musique]
imprévisions doutes
en réalité rien n'avait été prévu en
contrepartie et donc on s'est retrouvé
avec mon excellent collègue jean-ymond
Hugonnet a fait un rapport pour essayer
de trouver des pistes
sauf que ces pistes certes sont
intéressantes mais elles ne sont fondées
madame la ministre que s'il y a une
réforme de l'audiovisuel cette fameuse
réforme dont on parle sans arrêt depuis
2017 mais dont nous n'avons pas le
commencement de réalisation on avait
bien eu un texte qui est allé à
l'Assemblée nationale qui n'est jamais
arrivé ici
qui a été visiblement en grande partie
abandonnée même si vous en reprenez
certains éléments et dans la pratique on
se retrouve avec un élément qui pour moi
est franchement une aberration on ne se
remet pas en cause sur le contour le
périmètre du service public sur les
missions du service public et on ne
parle que d'argent
combien bah c'est simple on prend le
budget de l'année d'avant on rajoute
deux ou trois pour cent puis l'année
d'après on fait la même chose puis la
même chose puis la même chose sans
jamais redéfinir l'émission du service
public et ce qu'on attend du service
public il y a donc là un vrai sujet
moi j'ai donné un commission des
finances après beaucoup d'hésitations un
avis favorable au budget à 3 milliards
800 millions pour l'audiovisuel public
pour ne pas entraver son fonctionnement
mais madame la ministre est clairement
c'est un avis favorable one shot si je
peux me permettre en anglais pour
montrer ma maîtrise de quelques mots one
shot ça veut dire que si vous n'avez pas
en 2023 des éléments de réforme
permettant de faire progresser les
choses ce ne sera pas la vie pour 2024
ça n'est pas possible franchement je
conclus par là madame la ministre on
attend beaucoup de votre part en matière
d'audiovisuel public merci la parole est
à Madame Joël pour
la vie de la commission des affaires
étrangères et pour trois minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le dieu
visuel extérieur est un puissant tout
type de rayonnement dans le contexte de
tension internationale forte alors que
les valeurs de la démocratie et de
l'État de droit sont attaqués de toutes
parts et je voudrais ici féliciter et
remercier les équipes de France
médiumonde et de TV5 Monde pour leur
engagement sans faille et leur courage
en soutien de nos valeurs cette
audiovisuel répond aussi à une forte
attente dans de nombreux pays où les
audiences sont significatives le projet
de loi de finances prévoit une
contribution de l'État à l'audiovisuel
extérieur de 365 millions d'euros dont
285 millions pour France médiumonde en
hausse de 3,5% et 80 millions pour TV5
Monde en hausse de 4
hors compensation des effets de la
réforme du financement de l'audiovisuel
public la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public en effet été remplacé par
l'affectation au secteur audiovisuel
d'une fraction du produit de la TVA
ce mode de financement confirme que les
médias français sont des médias de
services publics et non des médias
d'État c'est une distinction qui est
cruciale à l'international pour
conforter l'indépendance de notre
audiovisuel extérieur et donc en asseoir
la crédibilité ce mode de financement
n'est toutefois acté que jusqu'au 31
décembre 2024
or madame la ministre votre ministère
semble considérer qu'une budgétisation
du financement aurait peu d'impact il
nous semble au contraire qu'une
budgétisation serait très préjudiciable
d'ores et déjà les autorités compétentes
du langue de Berlin on fait savoir
qu'une budgétisation du financement
pourrait remettre en cause l'attribution
à RFI d'une fréquence FM alors que nos
chaînes subissent déjà des interdictions
en Russie et au Mali une budgétisation
risquerait donc d'entraîner des
suspicions à l'origine d'un effet domino
c'est pourquoi aussi
l'autonomie des chaînes de l'audiovisuel
extérieur est essentiel une fusion des
différentes soucis audiovisuelles
publiques feraient passer l'actualité
internationale au second plan or la plus
grande incertitude continue à prévaloir
sur l'organisation de l'audiovisuel
public extérieur dans l'attente les
contrats d'objectifs et de moyens sont
reconduits sans vision claire de ce que
sera l'avenir la BBC elle dispose d'une
charte royale approuvée par le Parlement
depuis 2016 qui garantit son
indépendance la mise en place d'une
charte de ce type serait un facteur de
crédibilisation
supplémentaire pour France médias monde
en plus des considérations relatives aux
financement et à l'organisation des
chaînes déjà mentionnées sous réserve de
ces remarques l'augmentation des crédits
est un signe positif et donc notre
commission admirer
monsieur Guérini rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des affaires étrangères
pour 3 minutes
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
ça a été rappelé dans un contexte
concurrent Internet les incertitudes
pesant sur l'avenir de l'eau visuelle
extérieur constitue un handicap les
moyens des opérateurs français stagnent
entre 2018 et 2022 les dotations de
l'État aux entreprises de l'eau du haut
visuelle public et sérieux ont subi des
baisses de l'ordre d'un et demi pour
cent sans que les recettes propres des
chaînes en diminution en raison de la
crise sanitaire ne puisse les compenser
dans le même temps l'accroissement des
tensions internationales contraint nos
partenaires à renforcer des moyens
consacrés à leur audiovisuel et sérieux
c'est ainsi qu'en 2021 la chaîne
allemande DW et la branche
internationale de la BBC se sont vus à
louer respectivement
396 et 355 millions d'euros ces chiffres
sont à confrontés aux 255 millions
d'euros disposés France média monde
cette même année TV5 Monde répond dans
quant à elle à une logique différente de
sur quoi le secteur audiovisuel est tenu
de s'adapter aux nouveaux usages ce qui
fait bien et avec le succès que nous lui
connaissons France 24 le premier média
français sur Youtube tandis que la
plateforme TV5 Monde plus lancé en 2020
propose des contenus visionnés dans plus
de 200 pays et ici la promotion de la
francophonie de mère la pierre angulaire
le plurilinguisme reste un enjeu
croissant
RFI a renforcé au Sahel son offre en
langue africaine grâce à un financement
de la chanson française de développement
une étude montre que ces programmes sont
très suivis au Sahel France média monde
a par ailleurs dans le contexte de la
guerre à l'Ukraine renforcer son offre
en Europe orientale avec le soutien
financier du ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères c'est ainsi
qu'une offre de RFI 100% numérique en
ukrainien a été lancé en octobre 2022
nous appelons à la pérennité stabilité
des financements du ministère des
Affaires étrangères et de l'Agence
française de développement ce budget de
l'audiovisuel extérieur et plutôt
favorable même si l'inflation relativise
la portée il nous faudra rester attentif
aux évolutions des conditions
internationales particulièrement
troublée merci
monsieur legire importante pour avis de
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation de la communication
madame la Présidente de madame la
ministre mes chers collègues la presse
n'allait déjà pas très bien c'est-à-dire
années elle a ainsi vu ses recettes
divisées par 8 depuis 2000 car dépouillé
de ses ressources publicitaires par les
plateformes et victimes collatérales
d'une information désormais disponible
gratuitement et où chacun est devenu
expert en tout ce constat nous le
partageons nous les payons depuis des
années et je sais l'attention que vous
apportez madame la ministre à cette
question si essentielle à nos
démocraties pourtant les éditeurs les
journalistes ne sont pas restés immobile
certains titres ont su développer de
nouveaux modèles économiques d'autres
ont bien avancé dans la transition
numérique j'ai ainsi réalisé au nom de
la commission de la culture un rapport
au mois de juillet dernier sur la presse
quotidienne régionale qui souligne les
difficultés mais également les
perspectives et les ambitions de cette
presse qui va du village au monde
adaptation avec le soutien jamais
démenti des pouvoirs publics à travers
par exemple le plan filière qui
enregistré des résultats remarquables
pour les imprimeries or les conséquences
de l'inflation sont venues percuter de
plein fouet c'était des fils encore trop
fragiles avec l'explosion des prix du
papier des titres juste à l'équilibre
plonge dans le rouge les autres
reportent des investissements pourtant
nécessaires de cela madame la ministre
vous êtes bien entendu nullement
responsable cependant ce qui vous
revient c'est l'accompagnement or si les
crédits de cette année progressent
essentiellement pour des raisons liées à
la réforme du portage du postage presque
rien n'est prévu pour compenser au moins
partiellement la hausse des coups du
papier je dis presque carnet de
disposition introduite dans le projet de
loi de finance rectificative prévoit 5
millions d'euros pour la seule presse
que Dieu ne nationale et régionale
l'ardoise se monte on en est pleine à
175 millions d'euros ce n'est ni sérieux
ni adapté il c'est important de
souligner que la presse n'a touché
qu'une infime fraction des 150 millions
d'euros du crédit d'impôt pour le
premier abonnement dispositif adopté
pour soutenir en sortie de crise de
pandémique et qui a été je dois le dire
torpiller par des lodeurs
administratives en voie d'être supprimé
cette année sans grande considération
d'ailleurs pour les quelques éditeurs en
particulier dans la presse en ligne qui
avait commencé à le mettre en avant je
pourrais compléter cette somme par les
500 millions d'euros de l'amende
infligée par l'Autorité de la
concurrence en novembre dernier à Google
pour non respect d'injonctions dans le
cadre de la rémunération des droits
voisins contrairement ce qu'on pourrait
penser la presse rapporte à l'état mais
on en voit pas la couleur en cas de
besoin donc 650 millions d'euros de
disponibles 10 % seulement de cette
somme serait la hauteur des enjeux du
moment il resterait toujours
585 millions d'euros pour l'État pour
cette raison Madame la Ministre et à
regret je dois le dire la commission a
décidé de s'abstenir sur les options des
crédits du programme 180 presse et
médias et de s'en remettre dans ces
conditions à la sagesse du Sénat je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Jérémy Baki
[Applaudissements]
remporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture d'éducation de la
communication
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la sinistreuse
ambiante semble avoir largement
contaminé la presse des articles à
l'armistes paru en octobre ont ainsi
fait étage site de la panique qui se
serait emparée du cinéma de son cri
d'alarme en un mot les salles seraient
aujourd'hui face à un destin funeste
sans grand espoir il est vrai comment le
nier que les chiffres ne sont pas à la
hauteur des espoirs de la pré-crise 50
millions de spectateurs à moins en 2020
et en 2021 par rapport à la seule année
2019 et une baisse de fréquentation de
30% pour 2022 année qui n'aura donc pas
permis le retour à la normale cependant
ils sont tombés dans l'angélisme je
crois important d'apporter quelques
nuances en ce constat les chiffres sont
bien meilleurs que la moyenne des années
90 qui s'établissait alors à 135
millions de spectateurs ensuite il faut
bien mesurer l'impact différé de la
crise sur les productions si la France a
maintenu un haut niveau de production
grâce il faut le reconnaître au soutien
massif des pouvoirs publics
comme je le soulignais l'année dernière
telle n'a pas été le cas dans d'autres
pays notamment aux États-Unis ou les
tournages ont été littéralement stoppés
pendant plus d'un an or le cinéma
américain est essentiel au cinéma
français les gros films font venir des
spectateurs en salle qui en profitent
pour découvrir les œuvres nationales
mais ces films pas encore terminé ou à
la sortie des Calais ne sont tout
simplement parvenus en salle les studios
visant plutôt 2023 on doit donc alors se
réjouir de l'immense succès de Top Gun
Maverick 7 millions d'entrée mais aussi
de la production française ambitieux
ambitieuse pardon qui a retrouvé leur
public comme la nuit du 12 de Dominique
molle il existe donc bien public prêt à
aller dans les salles ce constat est
d'autant plus vrai pour le public jeune
qui est le plus revenu au cinéma il
faudra certainement un travail
spécifique pour les publics plus âgés je
souhaite madame la ministre que la
campagne de communication lancée par le
CNC porte ses fruits et que vous
puissiez trouver enfin moyen d'échapper
aux sollicitations présentes d'un illus
prédécesseur ministre de la Culture
au ministère de la Culture enfin je
crois qu'il faut lever plusieurs
malentendus qui trop complaisamment
répandus finissent par détourner le
public des salles non le prix des
billets n'est pas astronomique à
quelques exceptions près il est en
moyenne de 7 euros et seuls 15% des
spectateurs paient plus de 10 euros leur
place non les plateformes ne tuent pas
les salles j'ai d'ailleurs pris
connaissance à ce propos avec intérêt
d'une étude Médiamétrie qui montre que
les publics les plus jeunes se
précisément qui reviennent dans les
salles déserte les plateformes de
streaming au profit des vidéos courtes
sur Internet
quel retournement de situation vous
l'aurez compris même si les défis sont
nombreux et requièrent toute notre
attention je suis persuadé que nous
devons pas les aborder avec pessimisme
bien au contraire c'est dans cet état
d'esprit que la Commission a souhaité me
confier ainsi qu'à ma collègue Céline
voulait espionner et à ma collègue Sonia
de la pauvreté une mission sur la
filière cinématographique que nous
abordons avec enthousiasme exigences
pour proposer au Sénat une vision
complète du secteur nous examinerons
notamment le dossier toujours
d'actualité de la chronologie des médias
dans des travaux de Catherine Morin de
saillie en 2017 ainsi que la somme du
CNC la commission de la culture a donc
donné un avis favorable à l'adoption des
crédits du cinéma pour 2023 je vous
remercie pour votre
la parole est un
Raymond Hugonnet
rapporteur pour un vide la part de
Monsieur excusez-moi la parole est à
Julien barjoton je comprenais pas
pourquoi vous étiez tranquillement assis
à votre place
merci madame le Président on se
ressemble un peu c'est pour ça
il y a quelque chose de réjouissant à
constater que après une période
pandémique qui nous a tous marqué les
industries culturelles connaissent en
2022 une très belle progression et
devrait rapidement dépasser leur niveau
d'avant crise je dis bien réjouissant
car en dépit des problèmes et des
difficultés à surmonter que je vais
évoquer sur la traduit l'appétit et la
curiosité de nos compatriotes pour la
culture sur toutes les formes j'en veux
ainsi pour preuve les chiffres
remarquables de l'édition supérieure de
15% à 2019 et quel signal plus
encourageant que le succès du Pass
Culture qui permet la jeunesse de
découvrir de nouveaux univers on a
parfois critiqué ce dispositif sous
prétexte qui ne servirait qu'à acheter
des mangas certes ce genre un très grand
succès connaît un très grand succès et
tant mieux mais il n'est pas assez
relevé que 60% des jeunes qui achètent
un manga avec le Pass repartent avec un
autre livre vous entrez pour One Piece
et vous sortez avec Marcel Proust tout
n'est pourtant pas rose dans le secteur
les relations entre auteurs et éditeurs
traversent une phase difficile la
signature d'un accord entre les deux
prévu le 25 octobre dernier a été un peu
la surprise générale rejetée par les
auteurs qui souhaitent ouvrir le dossier
des rémunérations s'il n'appartient pas
au pouvoir public d'intervenir
directement ils doivent s'efforcer de
joindre un rôle de médiation et je crois
madame la ministre que vous avez pris ce
problème à bras le corps car je connais
votre attention au livre et à ceux qui
le font le Centre national de la musique
doit trouver son rythme de croisière
après la tempête du covid quelle mission
quel financement quel participation des
uns des autres à cette maison commune
patiemment édifiée tel était l'objet de
notre table ronde de la commission le 19
octobre le gouvernement m'a confié une
mission sur le sujet la gageure est
élevée je m'appuierais bien entendu sur
les travaux déjà menés par le Sénat sur
ce sujet je voudrais saluer celle du
gouvernement cette ambition du
gouvernement qui a lancé le plan France
2030 au sein duquel un milliard d'euros
sera consacré aux industries culturelles
et créatives 1 milliard ce n'est pas
rien tous les amoureux de la culture
tous ceux qui ont conscience de son en
termes économique en termes d'influence
internationale ne peuvent que se réjouir
des moyens supplémentaires qui vont
structurer le paysage pour les années à
venir année 2022 oblige je ne peux pas
conclure sans un mot des conséquences du
choc inflationniste ainsi pour prendre
deux exemples la BNF consomme autant
d'électricité qu'une ville de 20 000
habitants avec son demi-million de
mètres carrés de surface vitrée c'est
plus une montagne qu'un gouffre en la
matière concrètement le surco estimé à
3,6 millions d'euros en 2023 ne doit pas
obéir sa capacité à mener des projets et
assurer l'entretien courant autre acteur
très concerné les libraires le secteur
dégage de très faible marge et doit
aussi suivre la hausse des salaires il
ne faudrait pas que le renouveau du
livre soit empêché par la difficulté
économiques de nos libraires il faudra
donc en 2023 faire coïncider les fortes
ambitions du secteur avec les
contraintes du moment sous le bénéfice
de ces observations la commission de la
culture a mis un avis favorable à
l'adoption des partie du programme livre
et industrie culturel je vous remercie
maintenant c'est bien à vous monsieur
Gonnet
rapporteur pour avis la commission de la
culture d'éducation et de la
communication
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues quelle est la
situation de l'audiovisuel public le
bilan du précédent quinquennat s'est
limité pour l'essentiel à un travail
d'assainissement budgétaire avec la mise
en œuvre d'une trajectoire budgétaire de
moins 190 millions d'euros sur la
période
2018-2020 la perspective de la campagne
présidentielle laissait espérer qu'un
projet pour l'avenir de l'audiovisuel
public pourrait émerger des débats pour
redéfinir sa place dans un paysage
largement bouleversé par l'arrivée des
plateformes or non seulement aucun
projet n'a émerger au cours des derniers
mois mais rarement la situation du
secteur aura paru aussi confuse pour au
moins quatre raisons première raison le
gouvernement a indiqué que l'évolution
du secteur n'était pas sa priorité même
s'il n'exclut pas totalement de rouvrir
le chantier d'une réforme au printemps
deuxième raison l'élaboration de
nouveaux contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens a été reporté d'une année il
faudra donc se contenter de simples
avenants et attendre la fin 2023 pour
connaître les objectifs et les moyens
que l'actionnaire en tant à signer aux
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public pour
la période
2024-2028 d'ici là les entreprises
concernées sont au choix dans l'attente
ou dans la cantine mutée troisième
raison la suppression de la contribution
à l'audiovisuel public cet été c'est
accompagné d'une solution de financement
provisoire pour par une part de TVA mais
c'est l'inconnu qui domine concernant
l'après 2024 ce qui crée un climat
d'incertitude préjudiciable dans les
entreprises concernées quatrième raison
enfin la fusion avortée entre TF1 et M6
fragilise aujourd'hui ces deux groupes
privés mais aussi France Télévisions
puisque la plateforme salto apparaît
aujourd'hui condamné du fait des
difficultés des trois actionnaires à
poursuivre leur coopération
par ailleurs la fusion aurait eu un
effet de rattrapage sur les prix de la
publicité qui auraient également profité
à France Télévisions le groupe public se
trouve donc doublement pénalisé au final
2023 apparaît déjà comme une nouvelle
année de transition c'est pourquoi je
souhaite rappeler les deux propositions
principales faites en juin dernier dans
un rapport conjoint réalisé à
l'initiative de nos commissions de la
culture et des Finances consacrées aux
financement de l'audiovisuel public
premièrement apporter des garanties au
financement des entreprises de
l'audiovisuel public à travers la
création d'une commission indépendante
chargée d'évaluer les besoins pluriels
de l'audiovisuel public deuxièmement
fusionner les quatre entreprises
nationales France Télévisions Radio
France Lina et France media monde pour
assurer leur pérennité et développer
leur offre numérique le projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 prévoit une hausse
des crédits de 3% destinés à compenser
l'accroissement des charges fiscales
consécutifs à la suppression de la cape
et amortir la hausse de l'inflation la
hausse des moyens est donc à relativiser
je souhaite maintenant que la nouvelle
ressource soit définie dès 2023 afin de
figurer dans les cônes 2024 2028 et de
mettre un terme à l'incertitude sur le
financement compte tenu des nombreuses
interrogations qui entourent l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel public la commission de la
culture a décidé de s'abstenir sur
l'adoption des crédits relatifs au
compte de concours financier avance à
l'audiovisuel public du projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 et sans remettra dans
ces conditions à la sagesse du Sénat
j'indique pour ma part que je voterai
ces crédits merci de votre attention
bien avant de d'ouvrir la discussion
générale et de donner la parole à notre
collègue Bernard fi Allaire je vous
donne un peu de visibilité si chacun
d'entre nous et vous est très
raisonnable nous pouvons finir l'examen
de cette mission avant la suspension de
la fin de l'après-midi si vous n'êtes
pas raisonnable vous reviendrons tous à
présider la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard fiadaire pour 5 minutes pour le
groupe RDS
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
la presse la télévision la radio le
livre la musique le cinéma sont
traversés par la même difficulté la
révolution numérique celle-ci a modifié
en profondeur les usages de nos
concitoyens et impactés le modèle
économique de plusieurs grandes entités
si l'on ajoute à cela la crise sanitaire
puis aujourd'hui l'inflation c'est dans
un contexte flottant ou sommeil enjeux
structurelles et conjoncturel que les
pouvoirs publics doivent accompagner
tous ces secteurs non sans difficulté la
tâche est immense l'absence à court
terme de réforme de l'audiovisuel public
comme la rappeler notre rapporteur
général en est peut-être le symptôme tôt
ou tard il faudra cependant qu'à
l'intervienne d'autant plus vite que la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
n'existe plus si nous ne sommes pas
nostalgiques de cette contribution mon
groupe partage quelques-uns des grands
principes préconisés par le Sénat à
travers sa mission sur le financement de
l'audiovisuel public
une stratégie de regroupement des
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public d'un
côté et une budgétisation des ressources
de l'autre
tout autant que le secteur audiovisuel
la presse écrite le livre et les
industries culturelles ont besoin d'un
soutien public fort les moyens de la
mission en hausse de 0,6% en
autorisation d'engagement et de 4x4%
crédiblement seront utiles par le plan
d'investissement France 2030 cette
orientation est indispensable comme j'ai
pu le dire pour la culture lors du débat
précédent ces secteurs sont également au
cœur du projet républicain
en particulier à travers le soutien à la
presse et à sa distribution il est
question de veiller au pluralisme de
l'information un principe indissociable
de la démocratie je partage le constat
souvent exprimé ici d'une réorientation
du système des aides à la presse il
mérite au minimum d'être mieux collée
corrélés avec ses objectifs de diffusion
de pluralisme et de modernisation
s'agissant de la distribution les lieux
du Rhône que je suis ne va pas se
plaindre des messageries lyonnaises de
presse le brillant second devenu premier
devant France messagerie pour reprendre
les mots du rapport de la commission
culture je ne parlais pas de l'OL pour
pas froisser mes collègues
cependant il s'agit sérieusement de
veiller à ce que les deux opérateurs
puissent survivre au sein de marché
structurellement en baisse
concernant le versant éditorial de la
presse je me réjouis de la bonne
résistance de l'Agence France Presse
dans un climat concurrentiel tendu avec
les grands acteurs de l'Internet l'AFP
délivre une information qualitative
qu'elle conforte grâce à son service
remarqué de vérification des faits la
stabilité en 2023 de la subvention
versée par l'État conformément au
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens
2019-2023 devrait conforter sa position
même s'il est défi qui concernent
l'agence sont loin d'être épuisés
je souhaiterais également évoquer la
situation du livre dont le modèle est
également fragilisé je m'inquiète du
blocage entre les éditeurs et les
auteurs qui ne parviennent pas à signer
un accord sur une plus juste
rémunération des secondes faut-il
rappeler une évidence au Syndicat
national de l'édition sans création il
n'y a pas d'édition
quant au librairie le soutien qui leur a
été apporté durant la pandémie a été
essentielle elles attendent toutefois un
geste concernant le seuil minimal pour
les frais de port j'en profite pour
évoquer le sort de plus en plus
incertain des quelques 150 librairies
expatriées qui souffrent encore
davantage du problème des frais de port
aggravés par celui des délais de
livraison pour leurs clients il faut
absolument les aider car elle représente
indiscutablement un levier de la
Francophonie dans le monde enfin je
terminerai par un mot sur le cinéma
durement éprouvé pendant la pandémie ce
secteur inquiète depuis longtemps et
après avoir cité Malraux tout à l'heure
je citerai Mitterrand devant le
Parlement européen en 95 qui disait
alors que nous célébrons le centenaire
du cinéma l'art le plus populaire du
siècle n'a jamais été si menacée dans
chacun de nos pays il n'a d'ailleurs
plus besoin d'être menacé dans un
certain nombre de ces pays-là
il a déjà disparu depuis cette date le
modèle français résiste il faut dire que
le CNC accompagne plutôt bien les
mutations auxquelles le cinéma doit
faire face nous devons sonpendant
toujours rester attentifs à l'équilibre
à trouver avec les plateformes de
streaming la principale menace une fois
encore travailler au maintien d'une
création cinématographique française
dynamique c'est contribué au rayonnement
de notre pays et de notre souveraineté
culturelle dans le monde mes chers
collègues dans ce contexte le RDC votera
les crédits de la mission merci la
parole est à Monsieur Max Brisson pour 5
minutes pour le groupe les républicains
alors nous débattons du budget de la
culture pour 2023 comme tout à l'heure
la question qui s'impose et la
pertinence du fléchage des crédits à
louer ainsi pendant que l'industrie du
livre de la presse se débat contre
l'inflation des prix du papier que c'est
de la musique fait face aux évolutions
comportementales de ces consommateurs et
nous bénéficient pas de CNM efficient
celle du cinéma rencontre d'une peste
inquiétante de fréquentation alors que
ça mon cell pour les salles la menace
d'une remise en cause de la chronologie
des médias une industrie quant à elle ne
cesse de tirer habilement son épingle du
jeu c'est celle des jeux vidéo qui
enregistent une progression
exceptionnelle de son activité de 13,5%
sur les deux dernières années au point
de faire de la France l'un des
principaux leaders du marché notamment
dans celui des éditions un exemple qui
invite à l'optimisme comme je le disais
tout à l'heure votre projet de budget
pratique vraiment compte cette diversité
des situations dans le flécha crédit à
louer la réponse est disons
insuffisamment pour autant comme nous
croyons comme vous madame la ministre au
retour des jours meilleurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs lront les
crédits accordés à cette mission
néanmoins nous avons un point de
divergence de taille que vous a déjà été
exprimé le traitement réservé à
l'audiovisuel public non pas sur la
suppression de la redevance en tant que
telle mais plutôt sur la méthode
employée car une fois encore comme l'on
dit Roger caoutchi et Jean Raymond
Hugonnet nous assistons impuissants à la
mise en oeuvre du d'une décision dont la
finalité à Paris aussi flou que la prise
de décision était précipitée mais nous
retrouvons nous pas là tous les
ingrédients d'un mode de gouvernance une
annonce inattendue qui aboutissent une
mesure que le gouvernement pris de cours
peine à justifier et à financer cette
mesure amplifie en fait une réalité un
pilotage
un pilotage à vue sans cap stratégie qui
ne génère que du malaise les personnels
de l’autovisuel public déjà inquiets
sont désormais décontenancés par une
annonce électorale dont la mise en
oeuvre a été imposée à marche forcée
sans que ne fut pris le temps de
réfléchir aux missions et à
l'organisation de l'audiovisuel public
dans un paysage bouleversé et qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec celui qui
présidait à l'élaboration de la dernière
loi d'orientation en 1986
je regrette donc le caractère précipité
de cette décision je regrette qui n'est
pas été pensée dans un cadre général qui
aurait permis d'anticiper ses
conséquences et de justifier sa
plus-value surtout je regrette que nous
n'ayons pas eu en débattre pour
s'interroger collectivement sur l'avenir
de l'audiovisuel public le format et le
modèle que nous souhaitons lui donner
autant d'éléments qui auraient pu
constituer le corps d'une loi projet
souvent annoncé mais éternellement
repoussé selon toute vraisemblable à
ronce ni 2022 ni certainement 2023 de
succès de roi 1986 date de la dernière
loi nous prenons acte avec regret de ce
nouveau rendez-vous manqué et pourtant
que de sujets à traiter sur la place et
les missions du service public sur le
droit voisin la chronologie des médias
l'indépendance des rédactions l'éthique
des journalistes les moyens et les
missions de l'arcom que de sujets
envisagés face à un paysage audiovisuel
éclaté et pourtant jamais on a autant
parlé de risque de concentration il n'y
aura donc pas de grandes loi sur
l'audiovisuel cela en fait de près du
prince isolé aura fait bouger les choses
nous en reparlerons dans ce que nous
rediscuterons des avenants au contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens pour l'instant
sans enthousiasme et poursuivre la vie
de nos deux excellents rapporteurs Roger
carotier Jean Raymond Hugonnet nous
voterons sans enthousiasme les crédits
affectés au compte spécial audiovisuel
public et avec un peu plus d'envie ceux
de la mission média livre industrie
culturels et voyez madame présidente que
j'ai tenu la mission que j'ai donne du
temps merci
madame
prenez exemple sur monsieur Brisson
madame Vanina polygat c'est à vous pour
5 minutes oui madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues lors de la crise
sanitaire le soutien public en faveur
des industries culturelles a été massif
il faut le dire les tendances futures
sont excellentes en 2022 les industries
culturelles ont vu leur chiffre
d'affaires augmenter de 10% pour
atteindre les 18,2 milliards d'euros le
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 leur
consacre plus de 700 millions d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement
s'agissons de la Bibliothèque nationale
de France nous sommes tous réjouis de la
réouverture du site Richelieu le 17
décembre dernier après un chantier de 10
ans la BNF et cette année dotée de 70%
des crédits du programme
on parle de plus de 232 millions d'euros
en crédit de paiement il faut rappeler
que les trois quarts du budget de la BNF
sont dédiés aux dépenses de
fonctionnement pour accueillir le public
dans de bonnes conditions et assurer la
préservation des ouvrages et documents
ces coûts d'exploser avec la crise
énergétique que nous traversons
concernant le livre et la culture
l'année 2021 a été qualifiée
d'exceptionnel tant les ventes ont
atteint des records je souligne le
succès du Pass Culture ça a déjà été
rappelé grâce auquel les libraires ont
pu bénéficier d'une hausse de leur
chiffre d'affaires c'est une excellente
nouvelle mais il faut prendre ces
chiffres avec précaution car il découle
d'une situation hors norme aussi pour
2023 le PLF prévoit près de 23 millions
d'euros en crédit de paiement restons
suspens la question de la hausse du coût
du papier
ainsi que la question des relations
entre auteurs et éditeurs et plus
particulièrement des rémunérations
au sujet de la musique enregistrer le
streaming a désormais pris le lead
je parle en mauvais français avec 10
millions d'abonnés en France et un
chiffre d'affaires en hausse de 13 % en
2021 les perspectives sont très
enthousiasmantes avec une prévision pour
2032 de près de 35 millions d'abonnés
2023 pardon je pense que c'est une
erreur de près de 35 millions d'abonnés
un service de streaming en France acteur
majeur du secteur le Centre national de
la musique a démontré toute sa
pertinence et son efficacité lors de la
crise sanitaire le projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 lui destine 27,8
millions d'euros mais des redéploiements
de crédit pourrait être prévus au cours
de l'année pour compenser la baisse de
ses ressources propres le cinéma quant à
lui a bénéficié d'un fort soutien
pendant la crise avec un montant total
de 430 millions d'euros dont la totalité
aura été dépensé à la fin de l'année ces
dernières semaines nous avons été
informés du recul préoccupant de la
fréquentation des salles les premiers
résultats de 2022
l'écouter un petit peu ou du moins la
laisser par exemple un peu de calme
à défaut de m'entendre
les premiers résultats de 2022 affichent
un recul de 30% par rapport à ceux de
2019 rappelons que le prend le plan
France 2030 réserve 350 millions d'euros
à la filière de l'image le jeu vidéo
cela a été dit est un secteur qui
affiche une belle croissance de 1,6% en
2021 5,6 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires après des résultats déjà
exceptionnels en 2020 c'est un secteur
d'avenir qui représente un vrai levier
d'attractivité et de rayonnement de la
France comme on peut le souligner
plusieurs acteurs majeurs de ce secteur
lors de la table ronde organisée au
Sénat le 12 octobre dernier il est
nécessaire de poursuivre les efforts en
sa faveur concernant la presse et les
médias le projet de loi de finance pour
2023 propose 371 millions d'euros de
crédit en crédit de paiement soit une
progression de près de 6% par rapport à
après la crise sanitaire la presse reste
fortement dépendante au financement
public n'est pas une situation tenable
sur le ton long notre groupe est
favorable à une évaluation des aides
afin d'étudier la pertinence des crédits
mobilisés restez évoquer le compte de
concours financier avant sa audiovisuel
public la suppression de la contribution
à l'audiovisuel public intervenue cet
été ne fait pas débat dont elle nous
paraissait injustée inadaptée en
revanche le financement du secteur par
le fléchage d'une fraction de TVA ne
semble pas être une solution
satisfaisante sur le long terme il faut
poursuivre la réflexion pour conclure
notre groupe s'inquiète des conséquences
de la crise énergétique et de
l'inflation pour les établissements et
acteurs culturels les plus fragiles
toutefois nous nous félicitons de la
reconnaissance de l'importance des
moyens fléchis par l'État vers nos
industries culturelles et créatives
grâce à ce soutien conséquent ces
industries participant au rayonnement de
notre pays et faisant sa force doivent
être
aidés pour cette raison le groupe Les
Indépendants votera ses crédits je vous
remercie merci
la parole est à Madame Monique de Marco
pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la grande majorité
des acteurs concernés par cette émission
médias livre industrie culturel se
trouve aujourd'hui en grande fragilité
une fragilité née du bouleversement qu'a
représenté pour les secteurs de
l'information et de la culture la
généralisation des activités en ligne
mais une fragilité qui a aussi été
accentuée hier par la crise sanitaire et
la fermeture des lieux culturels et
qu'il sera demain pas la mise sous
cloche du pays avec la tenue des Jeux
Olympiques
plus que les autres secteurs la culture
subit de nos jours une grande
disposition du au fait du prince comment
mesurer en effet l'impact de la
politique culturelle de l'État qui d'une
même annonce le financement d'un
milliard d'euros de projets culturels
sur 5 ans dans le cadre du plan de
France 2030 et de l'autre menace de
déprogrammer reporter les festivals en
seuls les secteurs numérisés comme celui
du jeu vidéo sans m'épargner et peuvent
se projeter sur le long terme l'avenir
dira également si la belle santé du
secteur du livre se maintiendra et je
lis avec inquiétude que la fréquentation
des bibliothèques municipales est
toujours inférieure de sa fréquentation
en 2019
en même temps la situation du cinéma est
plus inquiétante car le système actuel
repose pour partie sur la taxation des
entrées en salle
l'entrée en vigueur des décrets SMAD qui
actent la participation des plateformes
de vidéos à la demande au financement de
production française ne garantit pas le
retour des spectateurs en salle
la montée en puissance de la vidéo à la
demande durant le confinement et le
développement des formats très court sur
les réseaux sociaux
représentent une concurrence peu chère
voire gratuite
face à cette fragilité l'État doit
adapter l'aide financière qu'il apporte
à chacun de ces secteurs y accompagner
l'émergence de nouveaux modes de
financement pour protéger les forces
intellectuelles et créatives de ce pays
et pourtant ce budget met fin aux aides
exceptionnelles mises en place pour
éviter la disparition de ces écosystèmes
culturels
vous proposez madame la ministre d'issue
située le plan France 2030 dans le
détail cela représente 250 millions pour
le développement d'offres culturelles
immersive 350 millions d'euros pour un
appel la projet fabrique de l'image et
400 millions d'euros pour l'accélération
des industries culturelles
France 2030 a donc plus vocation à
soutenir des initiatives émergentes qu'à
préserver l'existant l'attribution du
pouvoir de la co-tutelle du CNC de la
Caisse des dépôts et des consignations
nous éclairent également sur la forte
logique économique qui sous-entend
l'appel à projet fabrique de l'image
échappant du fait au ministère de la
Culture nous ne pouvons donc pas nous en
satisfaire
la situation de la presse écrite nous
inquiète également
malgré le rebond de 2021 la question du
système de distribution reste irrésolue
aussi des aides à la presse devrait être
orientés et conditionner comme nous
l'avons évoqué lors de la commission
d'enquête sur la concentration des
médias
il me semble madame la ministre que le
gouvernement a laissé peu de chance au
crédit d'impôt pour le premier
abonnement nous avions d'ailleurs
déposer plusieurs aliments destinés à
l'étendre et à l'adapter aucun n'a été
retenu
l'avenir de l'audiovisuel public nous
semble aussi compromis après 49 ans
d'existence la redevance attiré sa
révérence elle est remplacée par une
solution provisoire de financement qui
crée comme il a été dit un climat
d'incertitude le service public a besoin
d'un financement stable et pérenne sans
être soumis aux aléas de la conjoncture
politique
ce financement est injuste car cette
ponction de TVA pour tous les Français
ils y participent tous au même niveau ce
qui n'était pas le cas je vous le
rappelle de la redevance
il est encore possible d'améliorer le
financement de l'audiovisuel public en
augmentant la progressivité nous avions
proposé un abonnement en ce sens là
encore rejeté nous attendons des
garanties sur la pérennité de
l'audiovisuel public ces moyens sont
indépendance
l'importance de protéger ce pluralisme
dépasse d'ailleurs notre pays tandis que
semaine des guerres de désinformation à
travers le monde vous avez souligné le
monsieur le rapporteur le succès de TV5
Monde à l'étranger en 2022 sur 300
millions de francophones
1,8 millions de visiteurs sont
originaires d'Algérie du Maroc ou de
l'Espagne ce n'est certes pas l'audience
de la BBC ou observice qui compte 350
millions de spectelli spectateurs mais
des élèves réserves d'audience reste à
conquérir
pour toutes ces raisons nous ne voterons
pas les crédits à louer à l'avance
obligé de public excusez-moi j'ai
dépassé mon temps
la parole est à Monsieur gatelin pour 6
minutes non non vous avez pas dépassé je
vous en empêcher
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues impossible madame la
ministre impossible à l'occasion de ces
discussions générales sur les médias et
les industries culturelles de ne pas
rendre hommage à Pascal Joseph un homme
de télévision exceptionnel qui nous
abrute allemand quitté la semaine
dernière merci
à travers les nombreuses fonctions qu'il
a occupé tant au sein des médias publics
que dans les chaînes privées ou dans le
monde du Conseil Pascal Joseph est ne
devenus nonobstance à retenir naturelle
à des acteurs les plus influents du
paysage audiovisuel des 4 dernières
décennies encore choqué par la
disparition de celui avec qui j'ai très
souvent eu le bonheur de travailler au
cours de ma vie professionnelle j'avoue
que la valanche des Loges dont il a fait
l'objet depuis une semaine mais Claire
chaque jour encore davantage sur
l'étendue impressionnante du respect
qu'il suscitait nous sommes ici nombreux
à avoir bénéficié de ces perspicaces
d'analyses sur l'état de notre duo
visuel et de ses mutations prévisibles
vendredi dernier Jean-Pierre Leleu notre
ancien collègue me rappelait combien ses
avis était inspirants pour les
législateurs que nous sommes son
expertise était toujours mue par un
souci rare de l'intérêt général sa
disparition prématurée est une
pertinence et ses publié sont
malheureusement trop peu nombreux comme
on dit en Afrique ce continent qu'il
chérit sept ans quand un sage disparaît
c'est une bibliothèque qui brûle pour
autant et dans le débat qui nous ici
aujourd'hui il serait bon je crois de
lire ou de relire les premières pages du
projet qui est étayé sa candidature à la
présidence des Français télévision en
2015 Pascal était un fervent défenseur
de l'audiovisuel public c'est la raison
pour laquelle afin d'assurer sa survie à
l'air du numérique et de l'explosion des
nouveaux acteurs internationaux il
considérait urgent d'entreprendre sa
réforme deux grands principes guidaient
son ambition à ce sujet d'abord que la
vocation première du service public
était de servir servir qui le servir le
public évidemment se servir servir et
non se servir qu'elle a tentation est
souvent forte pour certains acteurs de
l'audiovisuel comme d'ailleurs dans tout
le domaine de la culture d'oublier
l'utilité
le droit de cette loi sans même
auditionner le Sénat qui en était à
l'origine et qui adoptait en seconde
lecture à l'unanimité ce texte la
seconde ambition de Pascal Joseph en
prolongement de la précédente c'était
que la télévision publique devait porter
et être porté par un véritable projet un
projet de société autant qu'un projet
d'entreprise un projet visant à
rassembler pour résister à la
fragmentation toujours accrue du corps
social faire société pour retrouver et
surtout incarner les valeurs
fondamentales de notre République et de
l'État de droit pour Joseph la mère des
batailles alors du numérique de la
délinéarisation et de la
démultiplication des canaux de diffusion
étaient celles des contenus autrement
dit la bataille du sens et lorsqu'on
parle de contenu porteur de sens on
pense naturellement mais de manière trop
exclusive à l'information sa qualité son
indépendance et son pluralisme on oublie
trop souvent contact considérable de la
fiction du patrimonial et même du
divertissement sur les constructions
mentales et dans la diffusion des idées
la fameuse série l'instit que Pascal
Joseph porta sur les fonds alors qu'il
était directeur des programmes de France
2 en est une des plus belles
illustrations encore aujourd'hui là
encore au moment où nous semblons
redécouvrir l'importance des grands
narratifs et du rôle majeur qu'ils
occupent dans la consolidation de nos
identités collectives la vision de la
télévision selon Pascal Joseph témoigne
une fois de plus de son extrême
pertinence et de sa nature anticipatrice
et ceux qui vont pour notre audiovisuel
national vaut au moins tout autant pour
notre audiovisuel extérieur aujourd'hui
frontalement attaqué notamment en
Afrique par des narratifs autoritaires
développés par la Russie la Chine ou
encore la Turquie les paroles du
président de la République à ce propos à
selon le 9 novembre dernier lors de la
présentation de notre revue nationale
stratégique nous oblige alors madame la
ministre au-delà du vote de ce budget de
grand chantier nous attendent vous
attendent si nous voulons redonner à
notre devis visuel sa pleine
utile sociale dans un monde en profonde
transformation je vous remercie
monsieur Assouline David insuline pour
le spécialiste écologiste et républicain
madame la présidente madame la ministre
messieurs mesdames les rapporteurs le
budget que vous nous proposez est-on
tremplin il semble aller dans le bon
sens avec une eau s'afficher pour cette
mission mais c'est de l'affichage car
non seulement cette augmentation est
deux fois moins importante que
l'inflation c'est donc une baisse mais
en ce qui concerne l'audiovisuel public
il ne corrige pas la gigantesque baisse
depuis 5 ans qu'il a réduit à l'os au
moment où il est plus que nécessaire au
contraire de lui donner de l'oxygène
pour remplir ses missions essentielles
d'information et de programmes culturel
de qualité face à la concurrence des
grands groupes privés et plateformes
étrangères prédatrice à la
désinformation organisée et à
l'uniformisation des contenus en effet
l'audiovisuel public connaît une
situation très difficile vous avez
baissé son budget significativement
pendant 5 ans tout en vous privant de
moyens pour son financement avec la
désindexation de la cap sur l'in à
partir de 2019 puis la fin de
l'affectation de la Toce pour
l'audiovisuel public et maintenant la
fin de la redevance dans le même temps
vous avez réduit son périmètre avec la
fin de France haut et heureusement que
France 4 que vous aviez décidé de
supprimer a été sauvé in extremis grâce
en particulier à une très forte
mobilisation de nombreuses sénatrices et
sénateurs de la gauche et d'autres bancs
dans cette émission oui malgré les
discours convenus sur sa nécessité après
l'avoir dénoncé au grand bonheur de tous
ceux qui veulent sa fin honteux de la
République avait dit le président de la
République le service public de
l'audiovisuel a connu des heures sombres
sous le précédent quinquennat le plan
dit d'économie affectant toutes les
sociétés de l'audiovisuel public
décidait en 2018 pour 4 ans a constitué
une perte de 688 millions pour lui dans
son ensemble cela s'est traduit aussi
par le sacrifice des salariés avec 900
emplois supprimés télévision après des
nombreux plans de départ depuis 10 ans
et 4200 emplois à Radio France tous
équivalent en plein et vous venez de
parachever ce travail de SAP en décidant
cet été de supprimer purement et
simplement la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public pour financer
l'audiovisuel en lui substituant une
part de la TVA système de garantissant
ni son indépendance ni sa pérennité ni
la justice sociale puisque c'est l'impôt
le plus injuste que tout le monde paye
de la même façon qu'il soit riche ou
pauvres et même les personnes qui
étaient exemptées jusque là de la
contribution du fait de leur situation
de grande précarité
dans bénéficieront pas
sont dans devront y contribuer également
pardon oui la cape n'était pas juste
mais elle n'était pas elle n'était pas
moderne non plus puisqu'elle était
assise sur un mode de consommation
déclinant et qui n'est plus exclusif
aujourd'hui le poste de télévision alors
où l'on regarde sur une multitude
d'écran les programmes mais elle avait
le mérite de garantir l'indépendance
ainsi qu'une pérennité depuis sa
création il fallait donc la réformer
pour qu'elle soit non seulement juste
mais moderne vous n'avez fait ni l'un ni
l'autre nous avons fait une proposition
alternative à travers un amendement que
vous n'avez pas soutenu qui crée une
contribution progressive cette
alternative entraînait et entraînerait
une économie sur le coup de la de Vence
pour 85% des foyers fiscaux français
c'est une solution plus juste
socialement plus moderne car ne
s'appuyant plus au sol téléviseur et
surtout qui si tu arrives un financement
pérenne indépendant et direct nous avons
déposé une nous avons déposé une
proposition de loi en ce sens maintenant
donc l'avenir de l'audiovisuel n'est
plus garantie car son mode de
financement est temporaire en effet à
partir du 1er janvier 2025 il ne sera
plus effectif et vous avez fait savoir
que le financement du secteur se ferait
alors via le budget de l'État un schéma
qui avait pourtant été retoqué cet été
par le Conseil d'État je disais que
votre proposition d'augmentation de
budget était en trompe l'oeil en effet
elle n'est même pas à la hauteur des
prévisions d'inflation pour 2023 par
exemple quid de l'augmentation de 50% de
la facture d'électricité de Radio France
et de l'augmentation de 22% des coûts de
serveurs informatiques j'ai proposé avec
mon groupe un amendement première partie
du budget pour pallier aussi à ce
manquement mais vous ne l'avez pas
soutenu non plus cette augmentation
cette augmentation
traduira donc par une nouvelle baisse
effective pour notre audiovisuel public
pourtant il mérite d'être soutenu et pas
qu'avec des belles phrases alors que les
médias télé radio sont en baisse
constante depuis 10 ans Radio France et
France Télévisions ont connu des records
d'audience Radio France réunit 15
millions de Français quotidiennement sur
ses antennes avec une progression de 2
millions d'auditeurs en quatre ans
France Télévisions quant à elle touche
81% de la population française chaque
semaine tout est confondu représentant
plus de 50 millions de citoyens c'est le
succès sur le linéaire mais également
sur le numérique et due à leurs
investissements massifs sur fond propre
sur les trois dernières années ils ont
investi Radio France 31,4 millions
France Télévisions 511 millions pour
innover sur la même période avec une
progression de 34% en 2 ans ils ont
également réalisé un travail remarquable
et remarqué lors des confinements de
même le service public de l'audiovisuel
est essentiel pour le financement de
toute la création audiovisuelle et
cinématographique française sans leur
investissement important les risques
pour tout le secteur sont réels et pour
être entraînés la fragilisation de toute
la chaîne des acteurs jusqu'à la
production ce travail important réalisé
par l'audiovisuel public c'est aussi
celui d'Arte de France media monde à
côté et avec Radio France France
Télévisions Lina et télé 5 mots face à
la concurrence internationale avec
notamment les Gafan l'audiovisuel public
doit continuer d'innover et pour cela il
lui faut un investissement à la hauteur
de nos ambitions c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que nous voterons contre sur le
compte spécial avance à l'audiovisuel
pour la presse l'effort est insuffisant
face à la crise à l'inflation auprès du
papier à la crise du secteur et puis
toujours pas ce que nous avons demandé à
travers différents travaux une refonte
des aides à la presse j'ai pu parler
précédemment de création
cinématographique et de le pack du covid
sur l'audiovisuel public le cinéma était
également fortement impacté par cette
crise sanitaire
avec 96 millions d'entrées en 2021 la
fréquentation enregis certes une hausse
de 47% par rapport à 2020 mais
représente une baisse de 55 % par
rapport à 2019 deuxième meilleure année
en terme de fréquentation depuis 1966
cette situation est inquiétante pour le
financement de la création et ce n'est
pas la mise en application de la
directive SMAD qui me permettra de
combler ce manque de recettes d'autant
que la hausse des moyens du CNC pour
2023 sera seulement de 3%
donc inférieur à la finition attendue
pour ce qui est du livre le budget de
l'action est positif mais les
inquiétudes du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains pour le
secteur sont autres entre une
concentration dans ce secteur toujours
plus important l'incertitude sur
l'avenue d'éditis numéro 2 français et
l'impact que cela peut avoir sous la
diversité l'autre sujet inquiétant et la
flambée des matières premières si le
chiffre d'affaires des éditeurs a connu
une progression de de 12,4%, le secteur
connaît un vrai bouleversement les
petites maisons d'édition connaissent de
très fortes difficultés face au plus
grandes maisons d'édition avec des
marges trop faibles avec les temps
difficiles marqués par la pandémie les
éditeurs indépendants ont retrouvé les
lecteurs mais la crise du papier et les
manœuvres financières dans le secteur
sont inquiétants il faut aider ce
secteur plus massivement en fin de
l'industrie musicale n'est également pas
en reste avec une situation compliquée
que connaît l'ensemble du spectacle
vivant si le chiffre d'affaires de la
musique enregistré connaît une
progression la recette des billetteries
de concert baisse de 10%
nous avons nous savons tout ce qui va
manquer 20 millions pour que le CNM
puisse mener à bien l'ensemble de ses
missions il faudra en 2024 y remédier
même si c'est consolidés maintenant nous
nous attendons le rapport de Monsieur
Bargeton
pour finir ce n'est pas parce que nous
vivons une crise
énergétique et inflationniste forte que
la culture doit être minorée c'est au
contraire parce qu'il y a cette crise
énergétique sociale économie climatique
et démocratique que plus que jamais la
culture doit être
promu doit être au cœur des politiques
publiques pour faire autour des valeurs
qu'elle incarne République ensemble
la parole est à Madame Céline Brulin
pour le groupe républicain communiste et
écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les crédits de cette
mission sont marqués par une
insuffisante prise en compte de
l'inflation galopante et de la crise
énergétique que nous traversons par
l'insuffisance de moyens dans la
puissance publique devrait pourtant se
doter pour faire face aux plateformes
géant du Web et autres grands groupes
qui concentrent de plus en plus de
médias dans les mains de quelques-uns et
même par des choix qui risquent
d'affaiblir considérablement la
puissance publique à l'image de la
suppression de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public qui n’est en rien
un coup de pouce au pouvoir d'achat des
Français celle-ci n'est en effet que
provisoirement compenser par une
fraction de TVA l'impôt le plus injuste
qui soit et dont personne n'est exonéré
à la différence de la redevance et vous
n'avez pas anticipé le fait que cette
décision aurait pour conséquence de
rendre les entreprises de l'audiovisuel
public redevable de la taxe sur les
salaires ce qui nuance sérieusement
engagement d'une intégrale compensation
et qu'adviendra-t-il après 2025 nous
souhaitons que vous répondiez à cette
question lors de nos débats madame la
ministre pour ce qui concerne la presse
qui est avec l'audiovisuel public un
pilier de notre démocratie l'explosion
du prix du papier avec une augmentation
bien supérieure à l'évolution d'autres
produits menacent de nombreux titres et
du même coup le plus réaliste 150
millions d'euros devaient être consacrés
au crédit d'impôt sur le premier
abonnement décider lors de la crise
sanitaire le dispositif n'ayant pas
fonctionné pourquoi ne pas affecter ces
crédits à un soutien d'une autre forme
permettant de faire face à ces surcoûts
sans parler de l'amende de 500 millions
d'euros du par Google et évoqué fort
justement par notre rapporteur Michel
Laugier l'article 40 de la Constitution
nous empêche nous parlementaires de le
décider mais le gouvernement peut le
faire et il serait souhaitable que c'est
d'être privilégie les titres indépendant
et favorise le plus réalisme cela
pourrait même préfiguré une réforme des
aides à la presse comme la notamment
demandé notre groupe en proposant le
doublement de l'aide au quotidien à
faible ressources publicitaire dans le
cadre de la commission d'enquête sur la
concentration des médias concernant le
livre il convient de revaloriser le
niveau minimum des frais de port comme
le demande les libraires indépendant
puisque celui-ci est fixé dorénavant à 3
euros alors que les frais de port leur
reviennent à un peu plus de 7 euros si
effectivement ce seuil a le mérite de
présenter une première étape nous devons
aller plus loin pour conforter le prix
unique du livre et rétablir les
conditions d'une concurrence équitable
entre les libraires et les plateformes
en ligne je souhaite insister madame la
ministre sur les conséquences de
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie
cette augmentation considérable va
affecter les salles de cinéma et là
encore nous pensons aux salles
indépendantes d'autant que les problèmes
de pouvoir d'achat rencontrer par nos
concitoyens peuvent affecter la
fréquentation qui n'a pas encore
retrouvé son niveau d'avant covid elle
pèse aussi très lourd sur la
Bibliothèque nationale de France
laquelle fait face à un surcoût estimé à
3,6 millions d'euros en 2022 et près de
15 millions d'euros en 2023 celle-ci a
déjà connu la suppression de 300 postes
en disant alors même qu'elle voit ses
missions augmenter avec la réouverture
du citrique ce lieu la poursuite de la
numérisation des documents ou encore le
dépôt légal de numérique il est temps
d'engager un vrai débat sur le
financement du Centre national de la
musique les trois ressources dont
dispose le CNM ne permettent pas à
l'établissement d'assurer les missions
qui lui incombent d'accompagnement de la
filière musicale en effet avec la baisse
de 20 à 25% de la fréquentation dans le
secteur du spectacle vivant et en
l'absence d'un projet de loi de finance
suffisamment ambitieux l'année 2023
risque d'être compliqué une taxe d'un
ennemi pour cent sur le chiffre
d'affaires généré par le streaming
contribuerait à financer le CNM avec
l'avantage d'aller chercher l'argent là
où il y en a cette taxe constituerait un
modèle de redistribution qui pourrait
rapporter plus de 20 millions d'euros
chaque année enfin concernant le secteur
des jeux vidéo nous regrettons le manque
d'évaluation du crédit d'impôt dont le
secteur bénéficie celui-ci pourrait
d'ailleurs être conditionné à
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
dans un secteur où la précarité et
l'usage abusif des heures
supplémentaires restent très élevé par
conséquent en raison d'un budget bien
trop fragile à nos yeux pour des
secteurs essentiels à la vie
démocratique nous ne voterons pas ces
crédits je vous remercie
merci la parole était madame Sonia de la
pauvreté pour 4 minutes pour le groupe
Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
j'associe à mon propos mon collègue du
groupe Union centré région agricole qui
s'exprime RA pour la partie média et
audiovisuelle
je débuterai mon propos par l'inquiétude
qui pèse sur le secteur du cinéma les
Français ne sont jamais aussi peu aller
au cinéma depuis 1909 d'après les
chiffres du CNC le soutien au secteur
des salles de cinéma et donc urgent si
l'arrivée de nouveaux acteurs comme
Netflix Disney plus et Amazon Prime
profite financièrement à la filière
c'est à quel prix artistique pour quel
coût pour l'exception culturelle
française et pour quelle évolution du
public qui risque de s'éloigner encore
plus des salles
ce budget soulignons-le affiche un
soutien fort et bienvenue au CNC et à la
Cinémathèque française de même les
dispositifs fiscaux incitatifs pour le
cinéma maintenues et développé participe
largement à ce soutien
concernant le livre les nouvelles sont
bien meilleures après une année 2021
exceptionnelle en librairie le livre
continue de bien se porter plus de 10%
volume et on va leur par rapport à 2019
l'actualité du secteur est notamment
marquée par la mise en oeuvre de la loi
proposée par notre collègue lors d'Arcos
qui amène reconnaissance et oxygène à la
filière et un premier pas pour les frais
de port pour autant les coûts du papier
de l'énergie sont des menaces nouvelles
sérieuses à prendre en compte et à
suivre notamment pour les petits
éditeurs du côté de l'industrie
phonographique la dynamique est aussi
positive avec une cinquième année de
croissance d'affilée et une progression
de 14,3%
citons dans les nouvelles mesures
budgétaires le lancement du portail
national de l'édition accessible qui va
permettre d'ici 2025 de se mettre en
conformité avec les exigences
européennes en matière d'accessibilité
simplifier les démarches des personnes
handicapées pour se procurer repérer des
livres est un atout supplémentaire pour
la filière et une mesure d'inclusion
essentielle le Centre national du livre
quant à lui a les moyens pour accomplir
ses missions dotées d'un nouveau contrat
d'objectifs et de performance pour la
période 2022 2026 arrêt qui la rage
bienvenu de ses missions s'annoncent il
était très présent sur le soutien
économique à la filière et s'ajoutent
déjà désormais dans ses objectifs celui
du développement du soutien à la lecture
une politique culturelle et
d'émancipation majeure pour nous toutes
et nous toutes autre sujet la situation
de la Bibliothèque nationale de France
est à surveiller car l'établissement
doit faire face à de nouvelles missions
à plafond d'emploi constant notamment la
réouverture du site Richelieu le musée
ou le développement du débau légal
numérique l'impasse budgétaire lié à
l'inflation risque de conduire la BNF à
ralentir et repousser des
investissements importants la création
du Centre de conservation Damien la
sécurisation de l'esplanade du site
Tolbiac et le renouvellement de son
système SSI
venons-en au Centre national de la
musique son financement continue de
soulever de vie interrogations
l'accompagnement de la filière musicale
par cette institution impose une
réflexion approfondie quant à ses
missions et au financement
supplémentaire pour que le CNM puisse
plus les remplir l'influence du
streaming et durée du numérique prouve
que les plateformes à coup sûr ont un
rôle à jouer dans son budget le CNM a
soutenu efficacement la filière durant
la crise sanitaire mais les ressources
qui lui sont allouées sont inférieurs à
ce qui avait été envisagé au moment de
sa création nous attendons le résultat
de la mission de notre collègue Julien
barjoton pour donner enfin un cadre
optimal à son financement
je terminerai par le secteur du jeu
vidéo fleuront national et secteurs
économiques ultra dynamiques le fond
d'aide au jeu aux jeux vidéos jouent un
rôle en soutien à l'écriture la
pré-production et la production des
entreprises de création nous soulignons
cet effort pour un secteur très
pourvoyeur d'emploi et qui valorise la
France au plan international pour
conclure Madame ma ministre nous
retenons les efforts fait par le
ministère dans ce budget pour soutenir
les secteurs du livre et des industries
culturelles elles vont devoir faire
l'objet d'un suivi très attentif il
participe ces secteurs largement à notre
économie et font pour les citoyens bien
plus encore je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Madame Laure d'Arcos pour
le groupe les républicains
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
comme vous le savez cette mission
rassemble les crédits que le ministère
de la Culture consacre au développement
et aux pluralises et à sa politique en
faveur du livre de la lecture publique
et des industries culturelles elle
comporte de programme le programme 180
presse et médias et le programme 334
livres et industrie culturels il n'a
échappé à aucun d'entre vous que la
presse en faisant ensemble a
particulièrement souffert des années
covid et a dû faire face à une érosion
importante de son audience qu'elle n'est
pas parvenue à combler à ce jour la
désaffection du lectorat se cumule
malheureusement avec les difficultés
d'ordre structurel déjà ancienne en
particulier l'érosion de la diffusion
papier et la transition numérique
inachevée certes les pouvoirs publics
ont mis en place des mesures d'urgence
afin de garantir la continuité de la
distribution de la presse et d'aider les
acteurs les plus impactés par la crise
sanitaire mais dans ces aides madame la
ministre n'oubliez surtout pas la presse
de la connaissance et du savoir
ces mesures se sont d'ailleurs cumulées
avec les aides transversales dont
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques a pu
bénéficier en 2023 les dotations du
programme 180 évoluent de près de 10%
afin notamment de soutenir la mise en
oeuvre de la réforme du transport de la
presse mais cette évolution positive ne
tient pas compte malheureusement de la
très forte augmentation du coût de
papier en fin de compte le saupoudrage
des dépenses notamment fiscales et
sociales de contribue pas de mon point
de vue à traiter à la racine les mots
qui affectent l'ensemble des titres de
la presse s'agissant des radios
associatives acteurs de proximité
important le projet de loi de finance
2023 leur apporte une aide renforcée à
travers le Fonds de soutien l'expression
radiophonique locale abondait à hauteur
de 1,7 millions d'euros c'est une
nécessité de cohésion sociale et je la
prouve j'en viens à présent au programme
334 livres et industrie culturels pour
évoquer les crédits dédiés aux livres et
à la lecture
dans le contexte économique que nous
connaissons je voudrais émettre une
crainte celle de voir tout un pan
d'économie du livre s'effondrer comme
vous le savez les librairies sont le
commerce de détail le moins rentables
avec des marges extrêmement faibles et
des charges fixes élevées salaires et
loyers elles sont donc particulièrement
exposées aux conséquences de l'inflation
et j'appelle le gouvernement à la
vigilance sur ce sujet
permettez-moi également d'exprimer un
regret celui de la réforme mitigée des
frais d'envoi des livres achetés sur les
plateformes de vente à distance pourtant
voter l'unanimité en 2021 dans le cadre
de ma proposition de loi sur le livre le
montant de 3 euros minimum est la quasi
gratuité à partir de 35 euros d'achat ne
donne pas à mon avis au libraire les
moyens de lutter à armes égales contre
les Géants Amazon et de s'installer
sérieusement sur le créneau de la vente
à distance et j'espère surtout que
Bruxelles dans sa notification n'y
mettra pas carrément un coup d'arrêt
s'agissant du Centre national du livre
ces crédits sont abondés de 1,1 million
d'euros afin de lui permettre de
renforcer son action de soutien à la
diffusion des œuvres et à la présence
des auteurs sur l'ensemble des
territoires ces crédits supplémentaires
ont également pour objectif
d'accompagner les éditeurs dans la mise
en œuvre de nouvelles obligations
d'accessibilité aux personnes en
situation de handicap je ne peux que
m'en réjouir de même je salue l'intérêt
que l'État porte à la Bibliothèque
nationale de France qui bénéficiera d'un
abondant un bon moment conséquent de ces
crédits d'investissement et de
fonctionnement lui permettant de mener à
bien son ambitieux programme de
modernisation du site François
Mitterrand pour autant sera-t-elle en
mesure de faire face aux conséquences de
la crise énergétique je n'en suis pas
convaincu
concernant la musique enregistrée se
pose en 2023 la question cruciale des
moyens dont devra disposer le Centre
national de la musique pour assurer la
plénitude des missions que la loi lui
confie si madame la ministre de la
Culture a rappelé que le budget 2023 du
CNM était suffisamment solide son modèle
de financement a néanmoins avivé les
tensions parmi les professionnels de la
musique dans ce contexte la mission
parlementaire confie à notre collègue
Julien barjetton et la bienvenue et elle
permettra n'en doutons pas de dégager
des pistes pour un cadre financier
cohérent
avec toutes les précautions d'usage la
pression est forte avec toutes les
précautions d'usage je vous les
souligner que la piste d'un financement
au moyen de la taxe sur la diffusion
visio vidéo vidéo physique et en ligne
des contenus audiovisuels dit taxes
YouTube peut sembler pertinente plutôt
que celle d'une éventuelle taxe
streaming permettant de mettre à
contribution les acteurs de la musique
enregistrée payante je ne voudrais pas
conclure cette intervention sans évoquer
la situation du cinéma l'industrie du
cinéma semble retrouver quelques
couleurs de quelques couleurs depuis la
fin de la crise sanitaire même s'il
convient de rester prudent au regard de
la baisse de la fréquentation de 30%
observée entre 2019 et 2022 la situation
du Centre national du cinéma
c'est quant à elle stabilisée mais reste
fragile d'un point de vue financier en
dépit de l'augmentation de 1,9% des
taxes affectés en 2023 toutefois dans
son avis budgétaire notre collègue
Jérémy Bachy n'a pas manqué de souligner
le contexte économique particulier dans
lequel évolue le cinéma peut favorable à
la prise de risque ainsi que les enjeux
de la sobriété énergétique et du
remboursement des prêts garantis par
l'État je vous remercie merci la parole
est à Monsieur Jean agré pour le groupe
Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
bien madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
excuser notre collègue Catherine Morin
de saillie spécialiste de lieu de
visuels qui a été retenu par d'autres
engagements je voudrais l'associer
naturellement à mon intervention comme
l'a dit notre rapporteur jamais la
situation de l'audiovisuel public n'aura
paru aussi confuse un certain que c'est
en fin d'année 2022 nous devions entrer
dans une nouvelle étape après le vote de
la loi audiovisuelle portée par Franck
Riester mais nous voilà aujourd'hui au
point de mort puisque Roselyne Bachelot
l'a enterré en 2020 cette loi aurait été
cette loi aurait pourtant permis entre
autres de clarifier le modèle économique
et le modèle de financement
pourtant promise par Emmanuel Macron en
2017 elle semblait indispensable cerise
sur le gâteau cet été au détour du PL on
supprime la contribution de
l'audiovisuel public sans avoir pris
soin d'en évaluer les conséquences et
réfléchit un mode de financement
alternatif pérenne à l'occasion d'un
véritable débat dans nos commissions
vous le savez madame la ministre notre
groupe Union centriste
otile à la croissance de la dette
publique souhaitait le report d'une
année de suppression le temps
précisément d'une étude sérieuse et d'un
débat éclairé
aujourd'hui nous actons le fait que
l'existence du comte de concours
financier à l'audiovisuel public et
maintenu alimenté par une franque une
fraction du produit de la TVA
correspondant au niveau de dépenses
prévues par la trajectoire financière
des entreprises maintenant l'incertitude
demeure sur le mécanisme qui sera retenu
à compter de 2025 pour financer
l'audiovisuel public de manière pérenne
à cet égard nous regrettons que les
préconisations ne rapporteurs de
création d'une instance indépendante
chargée de proposer une évation
pluraluelle des besoins de l'audiovisuel
public idée défendue par notre collègue
Catherine Morin Desailly dans des
rapports antérieurs n'est pas été retenu
par le gouvernement par ailleurs les
crédits inscrits sont certains hausse
mais cela doit être relativisé car nous
avons découvert les effets fiscaux de la
suppression de la cape donnez non
communiquer lors du plf.r à cela
s'ajoute pour France media et Arte la
perte du droit de déduire la TVA ayant
pour conséquence d'augmenter leurs
charges en 2022 et 2023
reste l'inflation et les coûts de
l'énergie qu'auront des conséquences non
négligeables sur le budget en dépit des
économies réalisées la hausse affichée
des crédits ne se fera ne suffira donc
pas pour compenser tous ces difficultés
nous craignons aussi que ces moyens ne
suffisent pas à financer les nouvelles
priorités de ces entreprises français
les divisions doit être structurellement
et financièrement capable d'affronter la
concurrence et continuer à financer la
création
quant à l'audiovisuel extérieur amené à
jouer un rôle essentiel dans le monde
troublé et menaçant que nous vivons
l'actualité est là pour nous le rappeler
tous les jours nous sommes inquiets d'un
niveau de ressources insuffisant le
financement de France médiumonde et
d’arte né en effet plus suffisamment
indépendant une dotation d'État s'est en
substituée à une dotation publique voilà
pourquoi en l'absence à ce stade de
mécanisme de financement approprié et
inscrit dans une loi organique ce que
préconise ni plus ni moins que le
rapport demandé à l'igaque nous ne
pouvons que suivre la vie du rapporteur
et nous abstenir sur ses crédits le
groupe centriste madame la ministre
attaché aux missions de l'audiovisuel
public restera particulièrement vigilant
exigeant dans les semaines à venir pour
que les missions dont il est dotées ne
soient pas plus longtemps fragilisés et
les personnels rassuaient rassurés sur
leur avenir je vous remercie merci la
parole quand même elle se Joseph pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues alors que les
différents secteurs sont touchés par une
crise multiforme la hausse des crédits
affectés ne suffit pas à masquer
véritable difficulté sur l'efficacité et
la pertinence des dispositifs actuels
nous devons déplorer l'absence de
véritables réforme pour une meilleure
adaptation aux nouveaux enjeux les
usagers et les usages changent les
publics n'ont plus les mêmes goûts et
les acteurs de l'industrie culturelle
proposent de nouvelles démarches le
numérique est désormais une donnée
incontournable dans tous les médias pour
l'audiovisuel public il faut aussi il
faut ainsi reconnaître l'absence d'une
véritable réforme d'ampleur attendu la
suppression de la redevance
audiovisuelle est restée avant tout que
la traduction d'une promesse électorale
une décision adoptée sans vision
d'ensemble et sans solution concrètes
pour notre audiovisuel public rien n'a
été engagé sur son organisation qui
reste nécessaire
il y a quelques mois mes collègues Roger
caoutchi Jean Raymond Huguenet proposé
la création d'un média public puissant
et innovant pour répondre notamment au
défi du numérique en raison de la
concurrence des plateformes
il en est malheureusement rien nous
sommes loin de nos voisins allemands
britanniques qui ont su mettre en place
un réseau attractif et reconnu
la hausse des crédits doit pas faire
illusion elle vit surtout à neutraliser
les conséquences fiscales de la
suppression de la redevance le problème
du financement des médias publics et
premium si le niveau des recettes est
maintenu rien n'a été fait pour évaluer
les besoins de l'audiovisuel public et
l'horizon 2025 nous inquiète quant à la
presse rien n'a été fait sur la réforme
des aides sauf pour les aides à la
distribution ce qui reste insuffisant
pas de redéfinition des rapports entre
le système actuel des aides et le
contexte numérique nous avions émis le
vœu avec le récent rapport de notre
collègue Michel Laugier que la presse
régionale soit mieux aidée pour la
digitalisation en raison de nouveaux
usages constatés chez les lecteurs ce
secteur doit être accompagné pour qu'il
puisse réinventer pour qu'il puisse
trouver lui-même les solutions or nous
ne les percevons pas
pour rester dans le domaine de la
culture on doit saluer l'attachement des
Français au livre avec des ventes de
livres en haut ça a été évoqué mais ce
qui est gagné d'un côté grâce au goût
des Français pour la lecture peut être
hélas perdu par la hausse des prix du
papier rendant le prix des ouvrages une
abordable
concernant les frais de port pour les
livres ma collègue lors d'harco savait
déploré un alignement sur le modèle
Amazon le niveau minimum pour des frais
de port pour les livres et trop faibles
ce n'est pas un message sérieux pour
nous libère et pour l'édition
l'application de la loi sur l'économie
du livre est décevante les éditeurs les
libraires et au-delà les lecteurs sont
en attente de fortes décisions
quant à la musique il faut noter la
poussée continue du streaming c'est une
consommation nouvelle destinée à être
pérenne et qui pourrait être une base
pour d'éventuelles ressources le
financement du CMN du CNM reste posée il
est insuffisant et une solution pour ses
recettes s'impose quels seront les
nouvelles ressources adaptées au
streaming faudra-t-il une taxe sur cette
forme de consommation pour financer le
CNM là aussi nous manquons de
perspective clair
parlons du septième art et laisse lui
aussi éprouver par la crise le cinéma à
symboliser la vulnérabilité de la
culture face à la crise sanitaire nous
sommes sortis des polémiques sur
l'ouverture des salles mais la
fréquentation a chuté d'un tiers par
rapport à 2019 comme si les contraintes
des gestes barrières étaient restés dans
les esprits une véritable jauge mentale
qui substitue aux anciennes
parce qu'il manie l'image le cinéma
subit la forte concurrence d'Internet et
des plateformes numériques il y a donc
urgence à réviser les soutiens à ce
secteur comme le CNC s'y était engagé en
janvier 2020 nous sommes en attente de
décision forte comment redonner tout
simplement aux Français le goût des
salles de cinéma voilà un test pour la
politique du gouvernement enfin la place
du jeu vidéo se consolide ce secteur a
bien résisté à la crise et les
perspectives sont prometteuses la France
est bien résisté a bien représenté
pardon dans le secteur des jeux elle est
même une référence
soutenons la création si nous voulons
que notre pays garde sa place et comment
prendre en compte la nécessité de
préserver des jeunes publics donc nous
déplorons l'absence de réforme vitale et
nécessaire dans cette mission alors que
des perspectives positives existent donc
avec beaucoup de réserves nous voterons
les crédits de cette mission
merci
et madame la ministre c'est à vous
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Commission
messieurs et Madame les rapporteurs
spéciaux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je suis très heureuse de poursuivre
cet examen de la seconde partie du
budget du ministère de la culture à
travers les crédits de la mission média
livre et industrie culturel et le compte
d'affectation spéciale avance à l'audio
public
les enjeux couverts par le livre et les
médias et par notre duel public sont
fondamentaux pour l'avenir de notre
démocratie surtout à un moment où notre
pays est confronté comme la plupart des
sociétés démocratiques à une crise de
l'information nous sommes dans cette
aire de l'immédiateté qui avait si bien
analysé Pascal Joseph à qui vous avez
magnifiquement rendu hommage chère André
gatolin merci de cet hommage
effectivement recule de la confiance des
citoyens dans les médias transformation
des usages pertes de repères face à la
profusion d'informations diffusées en
ligne fragilisation du modèle économique
de la presse les défis sont nombreux
pour consolider les acteurs des médias
du livre des industries culturelles et
créatives et permettre à la France de
rester une puissance de rêve pour pour
reprendre des mots de Malraux ce budget
2023 se veut ambitieux je dirais même je
pense qu'il est historique ce sont 704
millions d'euros de crédits budgétaires
4,3% de plus que l'année passée pour
cette mission média livre et industrie
culturelle le compte d'affectation
spéciale avance à l'audiovisuel public
s'élève de son côté à 3,8 milliards
d'euros soit une hausse de un peu plus
de 3% par rapport à l'an dernier je m'y
étais engagé cet engagement est tenu non
seulement la compensation de la
redevance s'est faite à l'euro près mais
ce budget prévoit une hausse des
dotations aux sociétés de l'audiovisuel
public pour prendre en compte les effets
fiscaux du changement du mode de
financement et compenser les effets de
l'inflation
la mission média livre industrie
culturelle pour 2023 et orienté autour
de plusieurs grandes priorités je veux
d'abord évoquer le développement de la
lecture qui m'est très cher sur tout le
territoire dans la suite de cette
dynamique très forte qui avait permis la
lecture grande cause nationale s'il ne
faisait aucun doute que les Français
étaient attachés au livre aller à la
lecture vous l'avez tous dit la crise
sanitaire a été l'occasion de le
rappeler et de mettre en lumière notre
première industrie culturelle les
librairies et les maisons d'édition ont
été touchées par la pandémie mais le
soutien public a été au rendez-vous avec
de nombreux dispositifs sectoriels sans
compter sans oublier le plan de relance
pour les deux dernières années
le soutien au secteur du livre doit se
poursuivre ce budget est l'illustration
de cette ambition 10 millions d'euros
supplémentaires sont consacrés pour le
développement de la lecture sur tout le
territoire soutenir nos bibliothèques le
réseau des librairies les maisons
d'édition en région renforcées aussi les
manifestations littéraires nous lançons
également en lien avec le ministère des
solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées le projet d'une
nouvelle plateforme accessible à toutes
les personnes en situation de handicap
qui va référencer les livres adaptés à
chaque handicap ce sont 5 millions
d'euros qui sont prévus jusqu'à 2025 des
budgets spécifiques seront si versés au
Centre national du livre pour inciter
les éditeurs à adapter davantage de
livres pour les personnes en situation
de handicap des aides vont également
être mises en place pour financer
faciliter renforcer le transport des
livres ce sont plus un million d'euros
dans le budget via la centrale de
l'édition pour faire face aux
difficultés d'acheminement dont vous
avez conscience vers notamment les
territoires d'outre-mer et à
l'international vers les librairies
francophones un enjeu qui me tient très
pire le pluralisme des médias et l'accès
à une information fiable libre vérifiée
indépendante c'est un enjeu majeur je
l'ai dit pour l'avenir de notre
démocratie dans les mois à venir vont se
tenir les États généraux du droit à
l'information auquel l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés vont être associés
ainsi que bien sûr tous les
parlementaires qui le souhaitent pour le
secteur de la presse l'année 2023 marque
la fin du plan de filière presse qui
était l'un des plans majeurs du plan de
relance mais je veux quand même rappeler
l'ampleur qui a été ce plan inédit avec
377 millions d'euros qui ont permis de
financer les transitions écologiques
numériques du secteur est vraiment
réaffirmer l'attachement de l'État à
cette presse qui
là encore est un enjeu vital pour notre
démocratie le ministère de la Culture va
continuer à soutenir le secteur la
priorité que nous avions définies avec
la filière c'était la de la distribution
sur laquelle nous avons travaillé déjà
depuis plusieurs mois c'est pour ça que
le budget est en hausse de 17,3 millions
d'euros pour les aides à la diffusion la
compensation au transport postal
mais vous avez raison la hausse des
coûts notamment du prix du papier est
une préoccupation forte une
préoccupation légitime des
professionnels je sais que vous y êtes
tous attentifs et nous allons avoir
l'occasion d'en parler lors de l'examen
des amendements 2 millions d'euros sont
également consacrés aux études
préalables et au lancement des travaux
d'un projet qui est très important à mes
yeux la future Maison du dessin de
presse futur lieu d'exposition de
création et de médiation je veux
également vous assurer de ma volonté de
mener un état des lieux assez complet
des aides à la presse pour travailler à
cette réforme que vous appelez de vos
vœux je ne suis minisque depuis 6 mois
j'ai déjà négocié un bon budget mais
maintenant je vous l'accorde nous devons
travailler sur cette réforme des aides à
la presse qui n'est pas une mince
affaire pour le secteur des médias nous
continuerons de soutenir les radios de
proximité pour la troisième année
consiste cultive en augmentant les
crédits du fond de soutien à
l'expression radiophonique locale pour
accompagner la croissance du nombre de
radio associatives éligibles à ce fond
puisque nous sommes passés de 690 en
2017 à 744 en 2022
comme pour la mission culture j'insiste
aussi sur le fait que ce budget permet
de répondre aux besoins immédiats du
contexte énergétique mais aussi de
préparer l'avenir en mettant la
transition écologique de nos
établissements de nos opérateurs au cœur
de l'ensemble de nos politiques
publiques 8 millions supplémentaires
permettront d'accompagner les
établissements publics de la mission
média livre et industrie créative face à
l'inflation ça c'est en fonctionnement
pour le Centre national de la musique
900 000 euros sont prévus pour
accompagner la transition écologique du
secteur de la musique en 2023 c'est une
amorce évidemment il y a les années
suivantes je sais vous l'avez tous
mentionné l'enjeu du financement du
Centre national de la musique est au
cœur de vos préoccupations
le sénateur Julien barjoton vient de
commencer sa mission sur le financement
de la filière musicale dans son ensemble
mais je voulais tout de même vous
rassurer de manière très claire sur
l'étape 2023 le budget 2023 je vous
avais indiqué que le Centre national de
la musique avait des reliquats du plan
de relance je les ai revérifié il y a
autour de 20 millions d'euros de
reliquats qui vont s'ajouter au budget
2023 du Centre national de la musique
donc n'ayez crainte en 2023 le secteur
sera bien accompagné et nous aurons les
conclusions de la mission pour
rediscuter ensemble de l'avenir à plus
long terme
le secteur du cinéma vous l'avez tous
mentionné merci de votre engagement pour
nos cinémas
ce secteur a fait l'objet d'un soutien
sans précédent sans faille du
gouvernement pendant la crise sanitaire
il va continuer à être soutenu le
montant des taxes affectés au CNC va
atteindre 711 millions d'euros une
légère hausse par rapport à 2022
l'enjeu principal des semaines passées
et des mois à venir évidemment celui de
la fréquentation de nos salles de cinéma
vous l'avez tous dit une baisse de
fréquentation attendue à la fin de cette
année de l'ordre de 25% peut-être 30% de
baisse j'espère que 25% de baisse mais
je reste optimiste je suis optimiste
pourquoi parce que je puisse être
optimiste déjà dans l'histoire
au début des années 90 on nous avait
prédit la mort du cinéma parce que la
télévision elle est tué le cinéma nous
avions chuté à une fréquentation
annuelle de 110 millions de spectateurs
en 1992 et pourtant les salles se sont
réinventées les films ont été au
rendez-vous et petit à petit la pente a
été remontée et nous arriver en 2019
avant le covid à 213 millions de
spectateurs sur l'année donc c'est
possible c'est possible le cinéma
n'était pas mort par la télévision le
cinéma ne sera pas tué par les
plateformes par ailleurs cette optimisme
je le puise dans la comparaison avec nos
voisins européens quand je vois que
60% de baisse de fréquentation en Italie
40% en Allemagne ou en Espagne ou en
dehors de l'Europe moins 50% en Corée du
Sud je me dis que tout de même le
secteur du cinéma en France a mieux
résisté que les Français restent un
peuple de cinéphile et que nous avons un
vrai appétit pour les films français en
salle l'émotion en salle sur grand écran
comme ont pu le montrer le succès de
films comme revoir Paris la nuit du 12
en ce moment l'innocent Simone le voyage
du siècle ou encore novembre
l'état accompagne fortement cette
reprise à travers le Pass Culture aussi
nous l'avons évoqué tout à l'heure
puisque pour vous prendre un exemple
uniquement entre janvier et août 2022 ce
sont 2,5 millions de séances de cinéma
qui ont été réservés via le Pass Culture
c'est un vrai appui à la fréquentation
des jeunes et donc le public de demain
également je veux préciser quelque chose
par rapport au plan France 2030 que vous
avez été plusieurs à mentionner parce
que l'État accompagne le secteur du
cinéma aussi via ce plan qui est massif
qui est très ambitieux Madame De Marco
je voulais juste vous dire que le
ministère de la Culture est pleinement
impliqué
dans dans ce plan puisque le CNC c'est
le ministère de la culture c'est une
administration centrale du ministère de
la Culture même nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés sur cet appel à projet grande
fabrique de l'image qui vient d'être
clôturée 175 dossiers émanant de 13
régions vous voyez la diversité ont été
déposées on a la trois objectifs
soutenir des infrastructures de tournage
soutenir des studios de jeux vidéo vidéo
d'animation d'effet visuels de
post-production et soutenir des
formations parce que là on a un enjeu
aussi de développer les compétences et
les talents tout ça c'est le plan France
2030 et le notamment l'appel à projet
grande fabrique de l'image qui est très
territoriale et qui brosse vraiment
l'ensemble des secteurs des industries
créatives
j'en viens maintenant au compte
d'affectation spéciale avant sa
l'audiovisuel public qui augmente de
114,4 millions d'euros pour atteindre
3,8 milliards d'euros nous avons eu de
nombreux débats cet été je ne vais pas y
revenir surtout qu'il ne me reste plus
que 4 minutes 30 nous avons pleinement
tenu nos engagements je les dis je le
redis le PLF 2023 apporte une
compensation à l'euro près de la
redevance et des effets fiscaux liés au
changement de financement bien sûr nous
avons aussi tenu compte en partie de la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie et bien
sûr de l'inflation je ne reviens pas sur
tous les chiffres que j'ai explicités en
commission mais je veux rappeler que
toutes ces hausses entreprises par
entreprise ont été déterminés par l'État
sur la base de projections qui ont été
produites par ces entreprises et
discuter bien sûr avec elle
nous avons eu l'occasion à plusieurs
reprises d'échanger sur le calendrier la
trajectoire financière plus réelle de
l'audio de la République va être fixée
en deux temps dans un premier temps un
avenant au contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens actuels 2020-2022 qui va être
signé là d'ici la fin de l'année 2022 et
qui va fixer les cibles à atteindre et
la dotation publique de 2023 dans un
second temps hallucides travaux qui vont
évidemment associer le Parlement dans le
cadre d'un dialogue nourri avec les
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public de
nouveau contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens vont être établis au cours de
l'année 2023 et vont être adossés à une
trajectoire de dotation plus réelle je
l'ai dit je souhaite que c'est nouveau
contrats d'objectif et de moyens et une
durée de 5 ans pour se donner la plus
grande visibilité possible et j'ai déjà
indiqué quelques grands axes grandes
priorités qui à mes yeux doivent guider
ces nouveaux contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens nous avons parlé de l'information
sa fiabilité sont pluralisme nous avons
parlé de la jeunesse n'oublions pas les
derniers votre Royaume-Uni les jeunes
regardent sept fois moins la télévision
que leurs aînés des chiffres dont nous
ne sommes plus très loin nous avons
parlé de la création nous savons
l'importance du financement de la
création par le dieuzel public nous
avons évoqué la proximité nous avons
évoqué et je vous remercie aujourd'hui
de le rappeler l'importance de
l'audiovisuel extérieur surtout à un
moment de grande manipulation de
l'information et d'ingérence étrangère
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les quelques priorités que je
voulais réaffirmer pour cette mission
média livre industrie culturelle les
ambitions que je veux porter pour le
Duval public je voulais saluer votre
engagement sur ces enjeux et je me
réjouis de pouvoir poursuivre avec vous
l'échange nourri que nous avons entamé
ces derniers mois et je libère deux
minutes de temps pour la suite bien
madame Vénus
je vois que vous préfériez qu'on finisse
cet après-midi
je vous remercie je vous rappelle que
pour la cette mission de la Conférence
des Présidents a fixé la durée maximale
de la discussion à 2h15
ce qui devrait nous amener à 20h20
mais voilà on va voir comment ça comment
ça tourne donc si vous n'avez pas fini
vous savez que c'est reporté après
nous commençons avec les amendements
portant sur les cris de la mission
industrie culturelle avec un amendement
de Monsieur dessus de 526 qui est
défendu oui merci Madame la président
donc j'ai bien entendu la ministre que
vous rassuriez sur le le financement du
du CNM
cette année enfin l'année prochaine mais
il reste quand même des inquiétudes et
notamment des inquiétudes portées par
les petits acteurs culturels et donc
même si nous saluons la mission qui a
été confiée à notre collègue barjoton
sous les ressources du CNM elle devrait
rendre ses conclusions quand courant
2023 et donc en traduction PLF ça veut
dire plutôt 24 et donc pour nous
proposons pour soutenir les filières
musicales d'instaurer un fond doté de 20
millions d'euros pour l'année 2023 pour
que le CNM puisse tourner un bol d'air
financier qui devrait lui permettre de
passer l'année difficile avant de
disposer de ressources pérennes
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
retrait ou avis défavorable comme la
ville gouvernement et comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure nous avons reçu les
responsables du CNM qui n'ont pas de
souci financier pour l'année 2023 qui en
ont pour 2024 donc la mission de Julien
Bargeton décidémentricité doit nous
donner dans quelques mois des
orientations et à partir de là on
demandera évidemment à ce que le budget
soit réaménagé madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente demande de
retrait également considéré monsieur le
sénateur dessus que votre amendement est
déjà pris en compte puisque j'ai indiqué
un reliquat d'environ 20 millions
d'euros que j'ai obtenu en report sur
2023 donc il y aura bien un plus 20
millions d'euros dans le budget 2023 du
Centre national de la musique en
attendant de préparer l'avenir
monsieur
merci Madame présidente rapidement pour
pas rallonger les débats puisque la
mission qui m'a été confiée a été cité
il s'agit en effet de faire le point sur
les dispositifs notamment du Centre
National de Musique et leur bilan donc
de revenir sur l'historique et puis d'en
tirer des conclusions d'analyser le
marché ses besoins d'objectiver et de
documenter la réalité des besoins et
notamment des failles de marché qui
justifient l'intervention publique de
d'élaborer des scénarios de voir quels
sont toutes les pistes possibles avec
leurs avantages et leurs inconvénients
et puis enfin de faire un certain nombre
de positions pour position d'ailleurs
sur le Centre national de la musique
mais pas simplement de manière générale
sur la gouvernance l'organisation et la
stratégie en matière de filière musicale
en France donc pour toutes ces raisons
et par cohérence
vis-à-vis du rapport que je dois rendre
évidemment je ne pourrais pas voter cet
amendement mais mais en tout cas j'ai
écouté votre évidemment la défense de
votre amendement et croyez bien que je
m'appuierai aussi sur les travaux du
Sénat et pour les remarques nombreuses
des de mes collègues sur le sujet de du
financement de la filière musicale en
France merci beaucoup monsieur Assouline
nous soutenons en tout point l'état
d'esprit et
la volonté exprimée par cet amendement
mais on a pensé aussi à faire quelque
chose à l'encens mais symboliquement
tout de même dans ce débat le fait de
devoir gager sur des crédits pris à la
presse et très problématique parce que
le secteur de la presse aujourd'hui
n'est pas celui sur lequel on peut aller
chercher à grappiller des sous pour
alimenter le reste donc nous allons nous
abstenir
tout simplement je vais mettre voix cet
amende il est retiré trois amendements
de discussion commune le 650
le 679 monsieur fialer
cet amendement vise à soutenir le modèle
des éditeurs privés de service de
télévision et de radio à vocation locale
opérant dans les territoires d'outre-mer
ces acteurs jouent un rôle essentiel à
plusieurs titres ils mettent en avant
des identités des cultures et des
traditions locales par une offre de
proximité plurielle et diverses il
resserre les liens entre nos territoires
éloignés et la métropole une mission qui
s'est révélée cruciale pendant la
pandémie et ils assurent le rayonnement
de la France sur les bassins pacifiques
indiens et Caraïbes ces opérateurs
permettent également un accès gratuit au
meilleur programme des chaînes privées
hexagonales pour les populations locales
je n'oublie pas leur audience et leur
poids économique ils rassemblent près
d'un million de personnes chaque jour
sur trois zones et emploi plus de 500
salariés divers et environ 700
intermittents qui travaillent au sein de
groupe d'audiovisuels intégrés dans les
territoires et là ce malgré tous ces
atouts leur modèle économique est
aujourd'hui gravement menacé en raison
des normal de transport et de diffusion
liés à leur éloignement du territoire
national et aux spécificités de leur
zone géographique de diffusion donc
craignant que ces éditeurs télévisions
et de radio ne subissent le même sort
que celui de la presse région
quotidienne régionale notamment les
liquidations qu'on vécu le GIR et France
Antilles cet amendement d'appel vise à
sensibiliser le gouvernement sur la
nécessité d'accompagner leur modèle et
de garantir leur pérennité merci Madame
jasmin
pour le 564
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre cet amendement a pour vocation
d'accompagner et surtout de préserver le
modèle des éditeurs privés des services
de télévision et de radio à vocation
locale opérant dans les différentes
territoires d'outre-mer et à garantir
leur pérennité afin que à l'instar de
ceux qui se fait dans l'Hexagone et d'en
bénéficie évidemment nos concitoyens les
populations des Outre-mer continuent de
bénéficier de manière effective de la
gratuité d'accès à de nombreux
programmes de la diversité des offres
audiovisuelles du pluralisme des
expressions ainsi que de la mise en
valeur des identités et cultures locales
il s'agit également de préserver des
emplois direct et indirects environ
entre 500 et 700 en fonction des
périodes mais l'objectif infini et que
le gouvernement accepte de créer une
aide directe et pérenne allant en ce
sens dès 2020 pour rappel le rapport de
la délégation des Outre-mer de
2018-2019 avec comme rapporteur Jocelyne
videz et Maurice Antiste prévoyait déjà
à qu'il y ait une prise en compte réelle
la situation des Outre-mer à l'époque il
s'agissait de fermer France Ô nous avons
été opposés plus ou moins mais le
gouvernement a fait un choix et
aujourd'hui nous voyons que nous avions
raison contenu des conséquences que nous
voyons par rapport à la situation des
différents médias dans nos territoires
donc je souhaite vraiment que ce soit
pris en compte et que nos outre-mer soit
doté de moyens suffisants pour permettre
à ces médias de poursuivre leur activité
merci
monsieur rapporteur quelle est la ville
de la commission sur le 679 et le 64 qui
vous appelle échappé le président oui
moi je serai tenté d'abord dans un
premier temps de demander l'avis du
gouvernement parce que c'est évidemment
un système très spécifique avec quand
même une petite réserve sur les deux
amendements c'est qu'ils sont gagés sur
le livre et la lecture ce qui quand même
c'est un peu un peu difficile chacun
comprend même si je sais les obligations
de la LOLF mais que ce soit cet élément
là où le reste mais avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre leur rapporteur
sollicite votre avis merci madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur oui
c'est gâcher sur le livre et justement
je venais d'expliquer l'augmentation
dans le budget pour la distribution des
livres notamment en outre-mer là vous
parlez j'ai pas très bien compris si
vous parliez globalement de tous les
médias en outre-mer ou spécifiquement
des éditeurs privés de service de
télévision de radio à vocation locale il
y a eu effectivement une aide
exceptionnelle pendant la crise
sanitaire certes à l'issue de la crise
sanitaire on voit bien qu'il y a des
fragilités économiques plus
structurelles je considère un peu votre
amendement plutôt comme un amendement
d'appel qui va nous inviter dans ce
cette réforme des aides à la presse et
aux médias radio et télé donc réforme
des aides aux médias et au pluralisme au
sens large je pense à regarder de plus
près mais là j'ai pas l'évaluation très
précise et je voudrais pas
réduire l'aide que nous avons pour le
livre notamment pour l'outre-mer donc
demande de retrait
pour les deux
ok monsieur le rapporteur vous suivez la
ministre bien donc je mets madame Robert
oui merci
effectivement ce sont deux amendements
mais vous avez vu que le gage on passe
de 1 million à 10 millions c'est quand
même pas rien la différence l'évaluation
qui a été faite par notre collègue
victoire jasmin avec les acteurs et bien
de 1 million et bien sûr le gage sur les
livres à la lecture n'est pas nous ne le
souhaitons pas donc nous demandons à la
ministre de lever le gage d'un million
bien je mets à la Ministre ayant donné
la vie défavorable j'imagine que vous ne
l'avez pas le gage donc je vais mettre
aux voix d'abord le rendement 179 double
avis défavorable qui est pour
oui donc qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
164 maintenant qui est pour
qui compte
il y en a pas beaucoup et j'ai un vrai
doute
on recommence on la rejoue qui est pour
lever votre main franchement
[Musique]
on 13
14 qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté
le 721 Madame De Marco merci madame la
Présidente c'est amendement vise à créer
une aide exceptionnelle de 5 millions
d'euros à destination des éditeurs de
presse d'informations politiques
générales d'ici PSG il vient orienter
plus spécifiquement cette aide
ponctuelles vers les éditeurs de presse
qui touchent aujourd'hui moins de 350
000 euros par an or head spécifique au
postage et au portage soutenir les
petits éditeurs de presse
IPG c'est venir en aide à ceux qui sont
les moins aisés et des et qui souffrent
le plus d'augmentation significative du
coût du papier qui a plus que doubler
depuis janvier 2021 en effet les aides à
la presse en général sont déjà captées
pour leur pour leur grande majorité pour
la presse-papier plus particulièrement
par les grands groupes de la
presse-papier rappelons que le groupe
aujourd'hui en France les échos le
Parisien propriétés de Bernard Arnault
est le premier bénéficiaire des aides à
la presse en France avec plus de 15,7
millions d'euros en 2021 au seul titre
des aides individuelles j'espère que
conviendrez mes chers collègues que
c'était de ponctuelle doit être donc
être fléchée vers ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin des titres de presse
fragilisés par l'augmentation continue
du coup des papiers et qui nous incobe
de soutenir au nom de la pluralité des
opinions de la diversité des médias dans
nos territoires et de la défense ils ne
presse libre merci quelle est la vie de
la Commission
retrait ou des favorable c'est
franchement pas les éditeurs de presse
IPG qui sont ni les plus mal servis ni
les plus menacés donc dans tout ce que
nous avons demandé au gouvernement sur
la réforme des aides à la presse
franchement je pense qu'il faut attendre
un peu cette réforme sur la diversité
sur l'ensemble des aides mais c'est pas
les ipgs qui sont et de loin les plus
menacés qui plus est vous gaver là
encore sur presse et médias c'est quand
même un petit peu compliqué je le
reconnais
Premier ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice de Marco c'est enjeu du du
soutien au secteur de la presse face à
la hausse du prix du papier nous l'avons
identifié depuis plusieurs mois le Sénat
d'ailleurs également mis en lumière ces
difficultés à travers le travail du
sénateur Michel Laugier que je remercie
qui a remis un rapport à la fin du mois
de juin dernier dans le cadre du projet
de loi de finances rectificative pour
2022 vous avez voté il y a quelques
jours un dispositif exceptionnel et
ponctuel proposé par le député de Nîmes
à seglia à hauteur de 5 millions d'euros
ils y sont
plus largement en ce moment nous
travaillons à un dispositif qui va être
exceptionnel et conjoncturel de soutien
pour les éditeurs les plus en difficulté
pas uniquement éditeurs de presse IPG je
précise qui vont à leur coût de
production augmenter de manière très
très significative
donc je peux pas encore vous annoncer ce
montant il ne sera pas
il sera pris sur des crédits existants
redéploiement peut-être du plan de
relance ou en tout cas en gestion je
suis en train d'y travailler j'espère
pouvoir vous confirmer ce montant dès
que possible plusieurs pistes sont à
l'étude mais en tout cas il y aura
bientôt une enveloppe supplémentaire
pour soutenir les éditeurs de presse
face à cette hausse du coût du papier
donc c'est une demande de retrait
encore une fois je pense que l'intention
est tout à fait louable de cet
amendement mais je mets en garde sur le
danger de créer un autre programme alors
que l'enjeu est de faire que dans ce
programme un autre programme financé et
fonctionner sur le programme existant
alors que l'enjeu est de procéder à une
redistribution plus équitable à
l'intérieur et je suis complètement
d'accord avec le fait qu'aujourd'hui on
doit inverser la façon dont les aides à
la presse sont constituées
les grands groupes qui sont adossés à
des grands groupes très solides
financièrement souvent d'ailleurs
étrangers au monde de la presse
aujourd'hui reçoivent l'essentiel de
l'aide publique ce qui est antinomique
avec l'aide publique l'aide publique
c'est pas pour aider ceux qui sont
solides et qui ont d'autres moyens
privés de tenir et inversement toute la
presse qui est en consulter les nouveaux
entrants comme les petits sont
aujourd'hui qui n'ont qui ne sont pas
dossés sur de telles puissances
financières reçoivent le moins de l'aide
publique donc que ça il faut en mettre
les choses à l'endroit et y compris
avoir une augmentation de ce programme
mais faire un programme à côté en
fonctionnant ce programme je pense que
c'est laisser au gouvernement le choix
de choisir sur sur quoi il fonctionnera
et d'ailleurs il peut ponctionner sur
déjà la petite ligne qu'il y a dans le
programme pour aider
la presse indépendante et les nouveaux
entrants donc ça serait quand même
c'est une possibilité donc nous on
s'absiendra sur l'amendement mais sur le
fond on est complètement d'accord avec
l'intention je mets aux voix cet
amendement double avis défavorable qui
est pour
qui compte qui s'absta n'est pas adopté
le 680 madame Brulin
merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement propose une aide d'urgence de
3 millions 6 en direction de la
Bibliothèque nationale de France 3
millions 6 qui correspondent au surcoût
de l'énergie pour l'année 2022 monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez dit qu'il
fallait beaucoup plus pour la
Bibliothèque nationale de France je ne
saurais mieux dire mais vous avez évoqué
aussi le gouffre qu'il fallait combler
et nous proposons de commencer à le
combler
avec cette aide d'urgence je ne reviens
pas sur la situation que connaît
globalement la Bibliothèque nationale de
France mais pour faire face au surcoût
énergétique il nous semble que ce serait
indispensable et nous vous demandons au
gouvernement de lever le gage en ce sens
merci la vie de la Commission
retrait ou défavorable j'ai dit tout à
l'heure par non pas par plaisanterie
mais par provocation que si on fait
l'échanger toutes les fenêtres c'était
des dizaines de millions sur le surcoût
de l'énergie les responsable BNF
admettent que dans le redéploiement en
interne il parviennent pour 2023 je vous
cache pas madame la ministre que pour
2024 si évidemment il y a encore des
travaux et des charges supplémentaires
la BNF devra trouver des ressources
supplémentaires mais le budget de la BNF
a augmenté de 10% 4 ans il est à 233
millions d'euros qui plus évoqué sur
presse ces médias bon un moment ça ça
devient un peu compliqué donc je
préférerais franchement qu'on en reste
là merci madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente alors pour la
BNF en fait nous faisons une
augmentation assez nette au PLF 2023 de
sa subvention de 8,7 millions d'euros
tout de même donc 5 millions sont
fléchés pour accompagner la hausse des
coûts parce que on a évalué dans cette
enveloppe que j'ai présenté tout à
l'heure de 56 millions quels étaient les
établissements qui étaient de véritables
passoires thermiques
je reviens pas sur exemple des 10000
fenêtres c'est vrai que la BNF est une
passoire thermique donc nous venons en
aide à ces établissements les plus en
difficulté demande de retrait puisque
vraiment c'est pris en compte plus 8,7
millions dont 5 millions pour
l'inflation
donc je mets au bois cet amendement
double avis défavorable qui est pour
quicontre qui s'abschain n'est pas
adopté le 523 monsieur dessus merci
madame la Présidente on revient sur les
aides à la presse avec un moment qui
plus à un moment d'appel parmi les aides
à la presse on trouve beaucoup dédiés à
la presse nationale la presse régionale
quotidienne et hebdomadaire mais il y a
quasiment rien pour la presse
régionalement mensuelle bimensuel
bimestriel ou trimestrielle quand je dis
que c'est quasiment rien c'est pas une
image sur les 197 millions d'euros au
total d'aide à la presse les
publications régionales périodiques non
quotidiennes ou hebdomadaires
bénéficient uniquement des crédits à
louer à la troisième section soit 50 000
euros 50 000 euros pour toute la France
lorsque l'on regarde dans le détail on
s'aperçoit que le montant est si faible
que seulement 6 titres ont eu accès en
2022 ce chiffre est surprenant car
lorsque conçu que la liste des
publications d'informations politiques
et générales régionales autre que
quotidienne et hebdomadaire publié par
la CPP AP on s'aperçoit que celle-ci
contient 138 publications sur le
territoire 6 titres aidés sur ensuite il
y a un ras-le-bol qui commence à
s'installer chez certaines publications
un sentiment que les aides sont
focalisés sur les titres proches des
lieux de pouvoir sur ceux qui maîtrisent
le système il y a surtout le sentiment
qu'il faut revoir d'urgence les
procédures d'attribution des aides du
ministère pour être éligible aux aides
au pluralisme il faut remplir quatre
critères que ces 138 titres remplissent
toutes tous un taux si faible
attribution n'est donc pas
compréhensible ces journaux n'ont pas
les moyens et les ressources humaines
nécessaires pour disposer d'effectifs
spécialisés dans les relations avec
votre ministère donc il est temps de
leur simplifier la vie c'est l'objet de
notre amendement qui double le montant à
louer à l'aide à la pluralité pour ses
publications afin de d'éveiller les
consciences au sein du gouvernement et
l'inciter à revoir d'urgence ces
procédures d'attribution quelle est la
vie de la commission
retrait ou défavorable notre collègue
dit lui-même 138 titres 50000 euros ça
ferait donc 500 euros par titre même pas
donc c'est très symbolique moi je
préfère franchement qu'on aboutisse
comment la souhaiter à une réformes à
une vraie remise à plat des aides à la
diversité de manière à ce que le
gouvernement prenne un certain nombre
d'engagements mais reconnaissez chers
collègues que 50 000 euros pour 138
titres sur la diversité en région c'est
oui oui mais bon c'est unique je
l'entends bien c'est un amendement
d'appel mais j'attends plus du
gouvernement une remise à plat des aides
avant de mon double avis défavorable qui
est pour quiconque qu'ils obtient il
n'est pas adopté nous allons procéder au
vote décrit de la mission média n'est
vrai industrie je vous rappelle que la
commission des finances est favorable à
l'adoption des crédits de cette mission
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
on la joue qui est pour
qui contre
ils sont adoptés
nous allons procéder l'examen des
amendements sur les crédits du compte
spécial avant ça au deuxième public
l'amendement le 506 monsieur broyé ne
pardon madame de Marco excusez-moi je
suis transformée non non
cet amendement vie ça fournir France TV
les moyens nécessaires pour assumer ses
finitions lors du précédent quinquennat
le financement de l'audiovisuel public a
perdu 200 millions d'euros et lors du
pdfr 2022 il a été bouleversé par une
réforme menée à la hussarde c'est en est
en plein contexte inflationniste le
budget de France TV n'augmente que de 1%
alors que la société voici ce charge
augmentée de 95 millions d'euros ces
concours financiers n'augmentent que de
50,7 millions d'euros il est donc
impératif pour conserver un service
public de qualité de lui assurer des
ressources suffisantes et pérennes et
lui donner de la visibilité
pluriannuelle des ressources de
l'audiovisuel public
vous pouvez défendre les deux en même
temps s'il vous plaît
tout à fait cet amendement est un
amendement d'appel pour alerter sur le
coude que représente la réforme du
financement de l'audiovisuel public pour
les sociétés de l'audiovisuel public 22
millions d'euros supplémentaires pour
France TV un coup supplémentaire non
amorti par l'État ce fut une réforme
mené à la hussarde lors du PLF 2022 à
tel point que l'on constate après coup
que les nouveaux crédits n'étaient pas
assujettis à la TVA les sociétés se
retrouvent assujetties à la taxe sur
salaire 22 millions d'enfants passés par
l'État nous demandons que l'État
compensé être perte mais surtout cet
épisode doit nous alerter et surtout
alerter le gouvernement sur les
conséquences de réforme menées un peu
trop vite
merci quelle est la ville de la
Commission
madame la Présidente chers collègues je
commencerai par le deuxième parce qu'en
réalité il est satisfait vous demandez
22 millions d'euros destinés à compenser
la sujets
il est satisfait puisque le projet de
loi de finance prévoit comme pour tous
les autres sociétés l'audiovisuel public
une compensation intégrale de la taxe
sur les salaires versés par France
Télévisions à hauteur de 22,4 millions
d'euros donc votre amendement est
pleinement satisfait par le PLF sur le
premier amendement le 506 vous demandez
45 millions d'euros de plus sur France
Télévisions
que vous gavez sur France médiamonde
c'est-à-dire quand même que vous prenez
20% des crédits complets de France
médiumonde pour France Télévisions
comment vous dire vu les difficultés de
France médiamonde je pense sérieusement
pas qu'on puisse baisser les crédits de
France médiumonde aussi importants
soit-il sur cet ensemble et dans ces
conditions un avis défavorable
je rejoins la vie du rapporteur
pour ce qui est de la compensation des
effets fiscaux des effets de l'inflation
du changement de du mode de financement
j'ai répondu l'engagement a été tenu là
j'ai le sentiment que vous voulez en
quelque sorte rattraper les années de
baisse du précédent quinquennat sauf que
ces économies qui ont été faites
finalement elles ont pu être faites avec
une ambition maintenue pour
l'information pour la qualité des
documentaires des enquêtes pour la
qualité de l'audience numérique
d'ailleurs des synergies nouvelles ont
eu lieu aussi entre Radio France et
France Télévisions on a pu voir France
Info par exemple naître France 3 France
Bleu aujourd'hui donc on voit bien que
ces économies n'ont pas impacté ni les
audiences ni l'ambition de l'eau du Val
public et ce sont ces ambitions qui nous
font regarder aujourd'hui pour l'avenir
par rapport au défi de l'avenir dont
j'ai parlé rapidement dans mon propos
liminaire et
ayons d'abord cette discussion sur les
objectifs avant d'avoir la discussion
sur les moyens pour la trajectoire
pluriannuelle que j'ai souhaité pour 5
ans dans les nouveaux contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens demande de
retrait sinon défavorable
très bien je souligne
oui non on peut pas nous dire en fait
que toutes ces baisses gigantesques
depuis 4 ans c'était finalement bien
puisque elles ont l'audiovisuel public a
rempli ces missions de façon
extraordinaire parce qu'en réalité ils
l'ont rempli à la sueur du front on les
a mis à l'os mais maintenant on sait
très bien que si on ne rattrape pas un
certain nombre de retards les
investissements nécessaires pour être
compétitif puisque c'est un domaine qui
coûte très cher la révolution numérique
ça coûte cher pour être à au niveau des
plateformes et pour être dans une
situation concurrence donc
considérer que finalement tout ça est
amorti avec maintenant tout va bien non
ça va mal et y compris le service public
ne va plus pouvoir
continuer même ce qui faisait avant par
exemple sur le sport quand Amazon arrive
vous allez voir si on peut être à la
hauteur
pour Roland Garros par rapport aux
offres qui mettent sur la table etc etc
donc il faut une augmentation ceci dit
nous avons nous proposer deux
amendements dans la première partie du
budget sur les recettes pour permettre
d'augmenter à cet auteur effectivement
et se rattrapage que vous réclamez pour
France Télévisions c'était un amendement
qui allait chercher un supplément de
recettes et un amendement structurel qui
proposait une alternative au
fonctionnement par la TVA avec une
contribution
progressive mais en aucun cas nous
pensons qu'aujourd'hui cette nécessité
de rattrapage du manque pour
l'audiovisuel public ne peut se faire au
détriment et à budget constant sur
l'audiovisuel extérieur aujourd'hui plus
que jamais dans l'audiovisuel il faut
renforcer l'audiovisuel extérieur qui
est aussi à l'os et dans la situation de
guerre en Ukraine de international c'est
certainement pas là qu'il faut baisser
la gare l'information c'est d'abord dans
ce domaine je vais donc mettre en voix
cet amendement 506 qui a reçu un double
avis défavorable qui est pour
je retire les deux amendements
publics par le groupe les républicains
sur les crédits du compte spécial avance
à l'audiovisuel public
je vous rappelle que la vie de la
commission est favorable
le scrutin est ouvert
laisse tomber plus personne ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 273 pour l'adoption
182 contre 91 le Sénat a donc adopté je
vais suspendre la séance elles sont à
reprise à 21h45 pour l'examen de la
mission recherche et enseignement
supérieur la séance est suspendue
[Musique]